thank you
uh starting over we will end the recess
and start the work session for House
Bill 430 4 30 is uh the bill that
requires one year of public education uh
prior to going uh I
I just lost it
all right I'm thinking all kinds of
stuff okay
any comments anybody like to make on 4
30.
Mary
education Freedom accounts were intended
to provide an alternative to public
education
um
and to
provide a resource for families to go
someplace else
um
this bill asks for children to be in
attendance in a public school
in order to be eligible for an EFA
um
it has an exception for
um kindergarten
in first grade but I think it's
in the true Spirit of what fourth of the
efas were intended to do
um so I certainly would support an art
to pass for this
um and I would hope that my colleagues
would vote with me
okay
this Bill had no support from my fellow
Republicans on the education committee
this is an anti-education Freedom
account and
I don't like it I would move to
inexpedient to legislate
okay motion been made in second into itl
recommend itl for house bill 430.
whenever you're ready
well if somebody like to say something
else please
I just I just want to respond to uh
representative Heath
we agree that efas were created to give
parents some choice on where to send
their kids
and that's the point of the EFA program
when this bill comes along and tells
parents that they can't exercise that
choice for a year that goes against the
original intent
and then I would also point out that for
every year of delay and having a kid get
into the EFA program it actually
ironically costs the state some money or
the taxpayer some money because that's
just another the EFA students cost the
system less than the public school
system does and so every year of delay
adds a small but an incremental cost I
think so I'm I'm comfortable voting Ito
thank you Mr chair I just want to
respond first of all
there's absolutely if a there is no
connection at all with a local in Lea or
local school district
um
homeschool children they used to be a
connection to the school district there
is no longer
in terms of the safety and well-being of
children I think being connected to the
school system for one year is not a bad
idea luckily anyone who participates in
an EFA has a number a student number
by which the EFA is provided but other
than that there is no
are those children being served in a
safe home are they getting the education
are they being taught by people who
actually have the ability to teach their
children I just am very concerned about
at least if they spent a year in a
public school there would be some
connection the family would be connected
somehow and this way
without anything in place
we are leaving children children
vulnerable I know that you're all in
favor of parents and
in that I am old and I've seen lots of
stuff over my years
there are parents who do not take care
of their children and there are parents
who will take advantage of these
educational Freedom accounts and will
not educate their children to the extent
that they should
I in defense of children and defensive
families in our Public Schools I think
it's important we have a responsibility
to look at the safety that's our
responsibility as state legislators and
I think we are giving that
responsibility away thank you Mr chair
thank you so um
just a quick few remarks here I do agree
with rep Edwards that this bill does
have a financial impact because
forcing kids who don't really want to be
there to go there for a year it's not
something that's just against you know
patterns choices and parents rights and
frankly I don't think it's good for the
kid but it also increases the amount of
funding that you know would not be
required If the parents were just
allowed to exercise their choices I hear
the concerns from representative Heath
in terms of Public Safety and being
connected to the school system is a bad
idea I will just say that those comments
don't seem to be about DFAS in
particular but about school choice in
general because any kid who is not in
public schools by the same you know
reasoning would be unsafe and you know
those concerns are really Way Beyond the
scope of this particular bill which is
not attempted to you know get rid of
school choice so
I believe strongly in school choice I do
agree that there may be bad actors but I
think there are plenty of safeguards in
the system to allow parents who do not
care for their children to be noticed
and you know that's what the dcyf is for
and so on so we do have the safety nets
in place to take care of that so I
genuinely
you know feel that those concerns are
already addressed but I do appreciate
and recognize them thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um U.S Supreme Court has ruled many many
times for the parents parents these kids
do not belong to the government they
don't belong to the schools they belong
to the parents they have the
responsibility and power to control the
education and upbringing of their
children
now that's one point another point
is that in roughly 2011 we
worked on homeschool Bill used to be
this used to be a red state to home
school
and we changed that to make it a green
state
and I remember some of the testimony
from Mrs Barrett from dcyf she said
we have one report of educational
neglect
and it was unfounded that's one
there may be more I mean you're going to
find
anomalies in all
uh these uh
areas but the big the big thing is is
that people still and I'm surprised
matter of fact I had one uh one of our
Representatives
from Milton come up to me and thank me
for help pass that bill and to end the
work on that bill because it it and it
look we are on a path of school choice
around the country this is not just New
Hampshire we're all over the country
matter of fact I uh one other point and
this is my last point
I was I was doing a business deal in
Alton
and next week they're going to vote
on open enrollment which is I mean
that's that's part of the school choice
movement and if it doesn't work then
we'll try something different but right
now it's not I mean our academic
achievement is going down
and that's not good and we've got to
figure out ways and even our own
education commissioner he homeschooled
seven children and I'm sure that they're
not educationally neglected thank you
alt anybody else have any comments
okay yes
as a substitute I thank you for just
giving me a moment to be a part of the
conversation
um and I know that I don't have the
background that all of you do so humor
me
um I just wanted to comment on the fact
that when this program was launched it
was framed
as a way to give school choice
to families
enrolled in public school that did not
have the financial ability
to enroll their children in a private
situation or
to I guess I remember it as in a private
school
and
a year after two years after I believe
that there was some research done and it
was found that 80 percent of the
participants in the program
had already
chosen to put their kids in private
school eighty percent of them were
already private school families and they
did not come out of the public school
program
so I think this bill is intended to
address
that problem
to perhaps
bring it back to the original intent of
the bill as many of us understood it
and
bring it back into
the financial realm that we all agreed
on as a house when we passed the program
and I think that this bill is a small
step to do that and address the initial
intent of the program which was to
assist uh
lower income families and give them the
choice
um
to leave the public school system
because that is not the way the program
has unfolded thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um first you know being a sub or not you
are sitting on the you know Division and
you are fully qualified you know and you
know we all have confidence that you
know everything that you are talking
about I wouldn't worry about that
um but basically I just want to say
really quickly that I wasn't in the
house when this bill was passed so I
will trust everybody's Recollections in
regards to what you know what was said
and what was done
but at the end of the day this bill
has a financial impact
where it forces kids to go to a school
where the state will end up paying more
and they don't want to be there it's not
just against the wheels of the parents
but we are spending more money to
essentially Force the kid to be in a
school where they their parents don't
want it to now
when I say Force I need to Define that I
agree that technically the parent could
stay out but as we said not everybody
can afford to step out so while some
parents may have the word with all to
just you know forego the efas quite a
few of them will be there
I also brought up when this was
discussed earlier that
for example kids that move in from out
of state and are older than first grade
the
even if their parents already know that
public schools in other states don't
serve their kids they will be forced to
try again here and you know our public
schools are excellent but again they
don't serve everybody well and I trust
the parents who already have made a
decision that that is not the best place
for their children and I would urge you
to again respect the ability of the
parents to make the right decisions for
their kids and provide them with the
support they need especially since it
you know saves the state money money
that can be used and put back into
public schools I mean all those funds
that don't you know that stop going to
the schools it is within the you know
this committee is prepared to greatly
increase the financing of public schools
you know we're gonna put way more money
into the public schools in this biennium
than we would ever you know lose from a
few kids that live out so I I would
appreciate if we would support the ideal
motion
any other comments
to the clerk to call the roll and the
motion is itl House Bill 430. motion is
ideal representative Petri
yeah yeah
um myself EA
representative Sullivan
no
representative Heath no
representative Murray
representative teller scheme
representative Weiler
and representative American yes yes the
motion passes Pardon Me Oh
representative just representative
Edwards I apologize I I I I'm a yes
I have no idea how I managed to skip you
I apologize it's that kind of morning
itl motion passes five to four okay so
we'll be referring it out to the full
committee at five four Ito
the next bill is House Bill 626 which is
the moving of administration of the
education Freedom accounts to the
Department of Education and away from
the third party uh this being managed
the process now
Mary
thank you Mr chair
accountability for multiple millions of
dollars is critical
and if the department of Ed
well the department of Ed has been
established and set up for years and
years
um to do just that they administer they
have their funds audited there's High
accountability from the federal
government as well as from state
government the LBA has been constant
visitors at the Department of Education
they are reliable accountable
if the Department of Education were to
become responsible for the efas they
could always contract out that to the
um
agency that is currently doing that
then at least there'd be
an oversight of these dollars I think
it's
responsible it's reliable
I think we have some responsibility to
our taxpayers for the amount of money
that is going out
with basically minimal oversight of how
it's being spent where it's going what
are the results
what's the accountability so I would ask
that you consider this bill because I
think its intentions are quite
viable
as former Deputy Commissioner I know how
hard people work at the department of Ed
we all know Caitlin we know how
responsible she is we've watched they
come to us all the time they talk about
how funds are being spent we rely on
what they tell us
we don't have that same sense of
authority
over of the scholarship organization
so what I would ask that you would
support this Bill thank you Mr chair
man
um
there was a surprise how many people
applied for this program far more than
we had anticipated and yet
the organization taking care of that
never seemed to raise any oh oh me or
anything else they took care of it got
it done got the job done
maybe they have more flexibility than
than the
State program that they'd have to come
back to West for an increase in
something so even though there was an
unexpected increase we never heard any
anything about a problem or anybody that
didn't get the paperwork done on time so
again I go back to the fact that none of
my Republican colleagues on the
education committee supported this bill
neither do I so I would move itl
okay
for a second
yeah okay
yeah I just would like to add that it
seems to me that it's fiscally
responsible to bring it in-house and in
terms of accountability it's much easier
to see what is going on in the program
if it is in-house
um apropos what it would require or you
know what department of education might
need it seems to me it'd be more than
reasonable and easy from that 10 million
dollars if you took 2 million to hire
two staff people if you needed
additional people to do this and it is
far less expensive than the 10 million
dollars that went out this last year
without us really having any idea of how
it is you know how that mechanism is
working it would just be so much more
transparent and I really strongly think
that it's fiscally responsible to do it
in-house within the Department of
Education so I would urge you know
considering that it's a small change but
I think it would make a big deal a big
change in terms of how uh the the
program is administered in New Hampshire
for the benefit of the New Hampshire
people I am very big on the fiscal
responsibility of it and the
accountability and the transparency that
it would provide and you know it would
we could do that for a few million as
opposed to the 10 million that
continually goes out or however much it
will be the 10 percent is a hefty charge
in my mind
right
um Kate just took care of it okay
comment thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you I agree that 10 million is a
hefty charge but I genuinely don't see a
reason why that charge was actually
happened I know the current loss is up
to 10 percent but it is within the
ability of this committee to adjust that
and uh I think that we may be able to
save more money by engaging with a
private agency and having them control
the cost thoroughly then we would be
able to do that with the Department of
Education
it is also much much harder to uh if we
ever need to you know
reduce the expenses it's easier to
frankly cut the fee that you pay to a
private agency by putting it out to bid
or finding other people than it is to
ask the Department of Education to
adjust those things
Mr chair yes I just would like to
mention that there was never an RFP sent
out
to anyone this was just in statute that
the scholarship organization would take
this
in terms of the representatives comment
that might be something that we might
want to consider maybe we should take
change from 10 to 5
um it's been established so they
probably don't need that 10 of every
single EFA anymore so maybe we should
consider that I don't know if if we want
to ask Mickey if he could draw up an
amendment to that effect
I think before we take any steps like
that we ought to have parties in to
discuss it Mary
if you're an a for trying all right
five stars on that one uh I don't
remember remember any comments from the
Department of Education on this bill or
any support of it and if they if they
didn't like the way it was going I
thought think they should come to any
one of us and ask us to put in a bill to
change it and the other thing that I've
noted through the years is that
within the department
there was except for under this present
commissioner there was very little
support of any alteration of the public
schools and I remember at one point
when we first put in charter schools and
we were reviewing the budget in the
education department and the person that
was the commissioner of the edu of
education at the time had totally
neglected to include the charter school
money in the budget and I I printed out
oh oh it's an oversight so I don't see a
lot of support for any variation within
the people in the department of
education but they're welcome to come to
us and if they if they think that
there's a way to do this better we're
open
thank you
with all due respect representative
I happen to be at the department when
the charter schools were being
established and indeed
if there was an oversight I don't
remember it I seem to remember
the reason why it was not in the state
budget was because it was on federal
dollars because they had a grant a very
large Grant and I believe Caitlyn you
could correct me if I'm incorrect on
that
you don't recall
that was before your time so just just
to set the record spray that um
we established many charter schools and
we had a nice conversation yesterday
about the velax and the great work that
they're doing and also we have Mills
Falls what a wonderful Charter that is
we have some wonderful things going on
in our charter schools and it's a
wonderful Public School option for many
children thank you Mr chair
the federal money was always for
startups because it would take as long
as three years to get a charter school
organized
hire the staff and get it going so the
startup money always seemed to come from
the feds however this oversight at the
time was not the federal money it was
the actual money for the students that
were in charter schools and
until they get a charter school started
we don't have any way to pay the money
because we don't have a thing and we
don't put money aside since there was
Federal money for startups but I also
remember
some iterations where
another oversight by the Department of
Education the money for checks for the
Federal grant did not get approved
because they didn't apply for it
so that's why I'm a little distrustful
of the of the people in the Department
of Education when it comes to any
alternative to public education thank
you
anybody else want to comment
okay then I'd look to the clerk to call
the roll on HB 626 as itl
thank you Mr chair again the vote is for
626 the motion is to Ideal
um representative Emerick oh sorry
I'm out the Border but I apologize
representative Petri
yes
representative Edwards yes
myself yes representative Sullivan no
representative Heath
representative Murray
representative tellersky
representative Weiler yes
motion passes five to four
okay uh 6 26 refer to full Finance on
the 5 to 4 vote
thank you very much for Subs
you're welcome back anytime
you're welcome
seriously though looking for a hug no
thanks
I think we're going to do uh just catch
up so if we if you've got other things
okay we're not planning on voting or
anything else nope I think
we might we may get involved in some of
the uh
sections of uh hb2 when the Departments
come in
okay okay
all right
so I have updated tracking sheets
through Wednesday so new working
documents and Caitlin Davis is here from
the Department to go over a couple of
those requests that have been added on
here subsequent to when the department
came to present their budget so she
could speak to a couple of those things
please join us let me pass these out
I need some more paper
get organized get smaller
you're right
gorilla
be cheaper
thank you
which should be
okay we've knocked some of these down
here
oh
you get to lead
I have a copy of what you gave the
committee
you're going to update it again so if
you can take Toms
here we go
foreign
nice to be here division two
good morning
um so the first handout that I gave you
that was from the Department of
Education was specific to the public
school infrastructure fund so I have had
a few questions that have come to the
department about the outstanding
projects left over in the public school
infrastructure fund so we had prepared
this document last time and didn't get a
chance to discuss it it does say the
security action for safe for security
action for Education safe grants on that
and I do want to just delineate between
kind of some ongoing work the department
has been doing and kind of the history
of this program I think we have a little
bit of time that we can talk about that
um so the public school infrastructure
fund was first established in
2018. there were three main goals of the
public school infrastructure fund it was
to support Public School infrastructure
it would support safety grants for
schools and
e-rate projects broadband and one not
project at schools
the fund was funded from leftover
funding after the rainy day fund was
topped off after at a hundred million
dollars so what was ever the remaining
amount was to give be given to the
Department of Education to distribute to
schools in a competitive manner so this
was in 2018
um the budget in 2000 and uh for 18.
um
almost immediately after the public
school infrastructure fund was funded
because so just timing wise just to
remind everybody so fiscal year 18
started in July of 2017 the state budget
the state audit has to go through all of
the financial statements need to be
finalized and that was the point that we
knew how much money was going to be
given to the department for the public
school infrastructure fund it was about
December January
um there was
um at about that exact same time that
the department started having
conversations with schools and and
um establishing this process for the
public school infrastructure fund the
Parkland school shooting had happened
and the majority of the funding that was
established under the public school
infrastructure fund went specifically to
fund projects for school safety so this
was 2018 this was the first time that
had happened
um the first large distribution of
funding there were some infrastructure
type projects and some e-rite projects
that were funded at that time but a
large majority of them were a safety
type projects the department ran a
competitive Grant process and school
districts applied to the department
there weren't caps on projects we did I
think it was an 80 20 split at some
point there was some local matching it
was involved almost every school in the
state received funding at that time for
these safety type projects an additional
10 million dollars was also added
um and I don't remember how that 10
million dollars was added I don't know
if it was through a budget or through a
build I don't know if Mickey you even
remember that in any way it ended up
being about 30 million dollars in 2018.
um as part of the state biennium budget
this past time go around an additional
million dollars was added per year to
the Department of Education budget plus
we had
um some money that was left over from
the previous round of funding school
districts had either come under budget
for some of their projects and gave the
additional funding back to the
department some of the projects didn't
go to for fruition because towns weren't
able to do their votes and whatnot so we
had
approximately three million dollars left
over and then we had the million dollars
each year that was added to the state
budget
um for this for for fiscal year 20
um 2 and 23.
unfortunately in June or May of um 22
the Uvalde school shooting happened in
Texas and this public school
infrastructure fund became a priority
again at that time and we had an
additional 10 million dollars allocated
to the Department of Education
um by gopher so Federal stimulus funding
to the Department of Education to then
give additional safety grants to school
districts we opened up a very very short
window
for school districts to apply it was a
competitive nature over the summer so we
were allocated that funding in for the
fiscal committee meeting in July we
immediately opened up a window to start
accepting applications and received a
large number of applications in July and
then opened up another window in August
and received another large number of
applications
so the Department of Education then
began its process of awarding those
funds which is Homeland Security reviews
all of the application and determines
the priority they have a ranking process
for those applications they provide that
information to the department the
department meets with the public school
infrastructure commission which is a
legislative committee and to look at
those rankings that were done mostly on
the basis of need by Homeland Security
and award funding so they did
three tranches of funding
um or sorry two tranches of funding um
the first they awarded all of the state
funding that they had left over because
we knew that was um we that was there
and then we worked through the process
of um all of the reporting and whatnot
that needed to be done for the federal
funding and at the same time was working
with fiscal to get that money allocated
to the department and then met again in
maybe September
um yes it was governor and Council in
September
um to award the second 10 million
dollars so out of those two short
windows at school districts applied we
had a large number of schools apply I
forget the total number of schools that
applied but we still have outstanding
um 20 oh so we actually it does have the
handout has it right here so it has 10
10 060 applications Department received
um and we still have 557 applications
not funded and 21 million dollars worth
of requests still outstanding to the
department
um that we have not funded at this time
now we do have a little bit of money but
it's a few hundred thousand dollars that
we're going to meet and obligate it's
certainly not millions of dollars for
this
um so these are the applications that we
had received
um the department did cap these projects
at a hundred thousand dollars a piece
and was very specific to the types of
projects that were um allowed
um so
um they were mostly
um the 10 million dollars for example
when to fund security and access
um Alone
um so the the second window was much
more tailored to specifically school
um school safety type projects and and
that's where we are so the Department of
Education had put in its budget
um a request of five million dollars a
year each year as a prioritized need and
that's where we are we're continuing to
ask for that five million dollars a year
to be added back to the Department's
budget to fund these types of projects
now there we do have potentially some
federal funding that could be coming to
us to fund a
number of these projects but we don't
anticipate it would fund 21 million
dollars worth of projects and then the
other thing is is you know are we going
to go up and open this up in the future
and let additional people apply and
whatnot so that's where we are that's
the whole history of the program that's
the request on behalf of the department
I just wanted to add that um there are
other schools besides public schools
that have access to these funds correct
for the second tranche of money the
federal money um that was all schools
that had access to them committee yes um
so for the first part um that's a that
is a good good thing to point out so the
first money the public school
infrastructure fund money which was the
state funding that money only went to
Public District and chartered Public
Schools the 10 million dollars
um some of that did go to non-public
schools they were eligible to apply for
those funding too although we use the
same structure application process
across the board for the second launch
of money
thank you but working the question right
now you have about 21 million in
outstanding requests and we are not for
now going to worry about what inflation
will do to those requests
um you said that you obviously at some
point may want to reopen I'm just trying
to understand the department has an idea
of what's the uh
ballpark of the potential total need in
the state based on the types of projects
that you are doing and the you know
number of schools I know I'm asking for
a you know shot in the dark but I'm just
trying to understand
in order to you know
properly plan and forecast for those
things
it's it would be useful to get an idea
of you know how much more is waiting yet
unapplied if and obviously since they
didn't apply you wouldn't know for sure
but do you have any idea I I don't that
might be a question for Homeland
Security Homeland Security has a very
rigorous process that they're working
with schools on a regular basis they'll
go out and they do safety assessments
and they identify Safety and Security
risks at schools and then we so we
handle a lot of the fiscal management
the grant piece side of things and then
as far as the actual needs of the
schools Homeland Security is doing that
and we feel like that's a very good
um
delineation of responsibility right now
because we we're great at the financial
piece and the grant manage piece but
they have a whole and you have staff
over there that that focus on that work
so if I could ask since you already have
a really good connection to the DHS and
have cooperated tightly on this matters
is it something where you could maybe
reach out to them and just
get us an understanding obviously what
the DHS identifies as a need may not
necessarily be a need that the local
school district feels that it needs to
be addressed or the local voters would
approve so I understand all those
limitations but
it would be good to have a feel of what
may be the pent-up demand for the lack
of a better word uh you know for those
programs because
you know when you open the
bonding Gates you want to kind of see
what may be coming uh from the other
side you know so I mean I think it's
fair to say it's at least 21 million
dollars wow I I think we all agree to
that thank you
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here Caitlyn
um
Pinkerton you mentioned giving money to
non
Public Schools is no what what status is
Cole Brown and Pinkerton and is there
others I mean that and and those are
those are Pub they get supported by
taxation is that correct you know
property tax so Pinkerton I don't know
if I should be like saying this on the
record because I'm not 100 sure as far
as the details and really what it it
Pinkerton and Cole Brown
have tuition agreements with towns and
they accept students via tuition
agreements
they follow a lot of the same standards
as public schools and as far as
accepting federal federal or federal
funding I believe they do not receive
federal funding directly I know Cole
Brown doesn't and I believe Pinkerton
does not maybe with the exception of
certain grants they don't receive
adequacy directly from us we give the
adequacy to the town of residency for
those students and they pass among those
funds but I do believe they would be
eligible to apply under at least the
safe grants if not also the public
school infrastructure fund so it's just
a tuition agreement basically to the
from the town they have tuition
agreements with towns yes thank you very
much
further questions
uh did the governor review this
prior to their preparations the
governor's office did not fund this line
and we mentioned that the other day in
our
um in our hearing okay
so this was a prioritized need requested
by the Department of Education
all right
he didn't put anything in hb2 for this
there was no request there's no funding
for the public school infrastructure
fund um tell me about the possibility of
federal funds um I know there's just
over the years we've had a lot of
discussion at the federal level about
these fun
securing the vestibules um getting alert
systems uh it's wonderful work what's
happened in this commission
um we've been meeting now I don't even
know how many years and the schools are
based on their emergency plans are much
more safe than previously and you'll see
when you go to a building everything's
locked and there are buzzers and it's
it's it's
not the friendly little schools that
used to be opened all the time there's a
lot of security but um there's more talk
about this I think in some of the
federal dollars coming you think there's
going to be more coming from there so we
have had some federal grants that we
have written for
um that would allow us to fund similar
type projects it doesn't necessarily
mean these projects themselves would be
able to be funded especially
you know since we accepted these grants
in the past they might have additional
requirements they might have a threshold
say of a certain level of free introduce
lunch be met or they might have to be a
project done after such and such date
um so anytime there's Federal funding
there's restrictions and so it's not
necessarily we can guarantee funding for
these projects but we will continue and
I have said this now um you know at
governor and Council and whatnot that we
will continue to seek additional
resources for any of these types of
projects and we are very committed to
that
um but it doesn't necessarily mean that
we'll we'll be successful thank you
because usually the federal funds go
specifically to Public Schools correct
right so that might be a category it can
only go to federals the the nice thing
about the stimulus funding I think we've
all learned is there's a lot of
flexibility
um as far as our ability to manage the
programs and who we could give funding
to and whatnot
um that same nice level of flexibility
is very rare especially in education
funding education Federal funding is
usually very prescriptive as far as the
uses and the time periods and the
reporting and whatnot so so you're
looking for this funding to really be
able to provide support to sectarian
um non-public
schools that are out there I don't think
that's a fair statement No Okay um so we
asked for this funding um under the
public school infrastructure line to
cover all the areas that are currently
funded um and we first so just timing
wise I think I think that
um
the legislature and you all don't
necessarily know how early the
Departments begin working on our budgets
I know you do because you worked at the
department but so when we're talking
about positions for example we I was
looking back at the position paperwork
that I submitted to my business office I
did that in March of last year
um and I know you're looking at it now
here in March of this year but it's
because I was like what I was trying to
remember what some of the positions were
but it's that long ago and so when we
had said let's put 5 million then the
Department's prioritized needs that was
last spring that was before the Uvaldi
shooting had happened that was before we
received that 10 million dollars and we
had said no we're going to put a
prioritized need in a 5 million dollars
a year because we think that continuing
to fund the public school infrastructure
fund and security and safety projects is
a priority priority of the department so
as you say Public School
um would Public Schools get priority
then in these funds so the five million
I believe would um
the Department's request is in the the
line item that we have for public school
infrastructure funds Mickey I don't know
if you can confirm that if we put it in
the two and one nine six four could you
check if that's an accounting unit do
you know can you do that
five million dollars
uh for yeah for this request yes yeah so
we would have to fear on mechanically
how you would want to do this if you
approved it what we've done in the past
is just done a general fund transfer to
the public school infrastructure fund or
if you want to put it in house bill one
with a different funding source but the
department has provided me a an
accounting structure to do this and it's
accounting unit uh 196. okay so that's
the the accounting unit that we set up
specifically for the public school
infrastructure fund and there's a law
RSA 19815 why why maybe
um I'm actually it's just it's reference
right here um in in your handout that
defines who those funds can go to so so
I mean you could certainly change that
through House Bill too if you guys can
change anything you want
um but that's really what defines the
public school infrastructure and the
current format and whatnot so all right
thank you and I mean to pick on you nope
you are always welcome Caitlin thank you
all right thank you uh how much
percentage-wise does these launch go to
non-public schools so
let's see it was a very and is that like
Paul school I mean uh so the schools
that received
um funding okay are on the list in front
of you here
so we have the non-public schools and
unfortunately I don't have a subtotal
specifically for non-public schools but
you can see
um looking through here starting on page
it says five of seven
down the bottom
um
and you can probably count up
I'm guessing just trying to sum this up
real quick in my brain probably a
million dollars maybe
looks like was requested by non-public
schools
but it looks like a fair amount of that
was not funded oh I see okay yeah for
example the Diocese of Manchester which
has a number of schools applied for
three hundred and thirty thousand
dollars but they still have two hundred
and seventy thousand dollars not funded
um so um
so quite a bit of the non-public school
funding quite the majority of the
funding I think it's fair to say the
majority of the funding went to either
Public District or public charter
schools and one of the questions if you
applied for round one
does that you hold over that application
for round two we did do that for this
instance
um it doesn't well and actually so round
one like first round one from the
2018-2019 was not held over for this
list this so this is technically
probably around
two three four I don't even know
um but when we opened it up this summer
um round one and round two were are both
in this comprehensive list just round
two references to one round one column
yes
so if I go to the last page bottom right
hand corner that's the 21 million
dollars
shortfall that has not been funded at
this time yes
my question
this is more procedural question I guess
because there's no way if we really know
the answer but it seems to me if a
school if the DHS comes into a school
and provides them a report on security
you know
they hand it to them
and there's no funds available from the
state
to do it it seems to me that a school
district would be derelict
by not doing the best they could to
execute what VHS gave them I'm asking a
question just because it seems
and I don't I don't know what that
process is I'm not even sure what um
Homeland Security gives them
it's a security assessment that I think
I I I think this might be a great
question for Homeland Security but I
just don't know the details yeah I'm
just curious because if you're if once
you're given a report that says you've
got to do a b and c and if you don't do
a b and c and something happens
it seems to me you have a certain
negligent liability in that I'm not a
lawyer I'm just saying
holy mackerel
Mary
I believe in our
in our infrastructure committee we we
talked about when the homeland security
goes out and assesses the need that
bumps them up on the
um I believe they did use that as one of
the criteria criteria oh okay so um the
work that they're doing is really
wonderful and they've been helping
schools for a long time so I think it
does have input into what happens
question
can I just to follow up on the you know
potential failure to act as an adhes
finding
um if I recall correctly the DHS you
know comes in when invited right you
don't they don't just go through the
schools without asking first the school
has to say I would like to be assist or
was it a every school got inspected so
every school is required just just an
emergency operation plan
I as far as the review process for the
Emergency operation plan again that's a
homeland security question
um and then they also additionally on
top of the emergency operation plan they
do offer a security Assessment program
um that is separate from the emergency
operation plan process that is a
required report that they must submit
I believe annually
now I I'm asking because I remember that
you know when I was in the school board
we asked you know we we didn't just they
didn't just come by without being asked
so in that sense I would say that most
schools that are asking are probably
already concerned and they're trying to
figure out you know how best to address
so uh I wouldn't be very worried about
any school who already asked for an
assessment showing concern then choosing
not to act I mean there may be
situations where they cannot get a
warrant article passed or whatnot or
maybe there are disagreements that the
issue is not that big or something but I
would I would guess that that's a very
rare type of situation
uh
I mean if the committee has time I know
you're very crunched on time and just
just let Mickey know and I can tell him
who the appropriate contacts at Homeland
Security that could come in and talk to
you about that but
it's
oh
I don't know
we got so much to do I mean I think
you're representing you need it is
sufficient for me I believe you no
problem uh I I'll give you a little
anecdote our church applied for a
Federal grant for security under it's a
a
501c3 program
and we've got as a pilot we were awarded
a grant for security doors you know and
keypad these little puppies instead of
keys
um
and we got the grant
but we can't find anybody to install the
doors
and it's been seven months we've been
trying to find somebody to come install
these doors but we can't
it's a reimbursement Grant up to a
certain amount so we've got to get the
doors installed before we before we can
apply for them and that's exactly the
way that this grant works too and we
have had some schools tell us that exact
same story and schools have through the
end of June to obligate the funding or
the funding is basically reverted back
to us even though we've never
distributed it to the school and we will
award it to somebody else
in small towns that have tight budgets
um it's really hard when you get a grant
a large Grant from the state that you
want to spend and you have a legitimate
reason to spend but sometimes their
budgets are so little that they can't
spend all those dollars first and get
reimbursed it really it can be tough
yes yep yep I'm fully funded but I can't
do it because I don't have the cash
okay any other questions
do you have any other areas you'd like
to
oh
so
um this so happens
okay Department of Education so
infrastructure fund
um
I can talk about the accountability
position and relative to that work so
this would be sorry in center of line 43
on our working document here
um so last week or actually earlier this
week at the end of um Tuesday or
Wednesday you had Mark here at the end
of a long day and I think he gave you a
lot of information very very quickly
um so hopefully he uh didn't go too
quick
um but one of his I think he expressed
some concerns and some comments about
accountability plans and some of the
information and some of the grant
proposals and what not coming to you
relative to some bills and
um so one of the things that the
Department of Education has asked for is
for an administrator to oversee
accountability plans so
um we did not ask the governor for this
originally in our legisl in our proposal
we it
um timing wise it we hadn't even
so accountability plans first passed um
as part of the extraordinary needs
grants process that was passed over the
summer and we began implementing this
fall and it was just timing wise we
didn't even have an opportunity to ask
the governor for in our budget so we are
asking now
um and I think part of this is you know
what the committee is going to do with
the funding formula and the
accountability needs plans is um
a part of this uh but so just for
example the department of education is
required to collect an accountability
accountability plan for the
extraordinary needs grants this is a new
requirement because extraordinary needs
grants which are an adequacy formula are
new
um just a reminder that Grant is
um
a grant that it goes through school
districts that have a high percentage of
free and reduced lunch pupils to a low
equalized valuation so it's specifically
targets towns like Berlin a town like
Bedford wouldn't necessarily receive
these funding with even though Bedford
has a low equalized valuation they still
have a high free and reduced lot or
sorry they have a low equalized
valuation but a low free and reduced
lunch number so it's a new Grant it was
um chiefly a priority of Senator
Hennessey last year it was passed in our
budget
um and then extraordinary accountability
plans were added as an amendment last
minute in the committee of conference
to the Department's requirement for
these grants
collecting these plans and managing
these plans was an extraordinary feat
for the Department this fall I would say
collectively across myself my data team
Mark and my accountability team probably
spent a thousand hours just trying to
explain to school districts the need for
the plans developing the templates some
of the tax implications of this work
because of the timing the funding what
could go back to
reduce taxes but you still had to do an
extraordinary needs plan and talk about
what you were doing for accountability
and your school district was that
that and explaining that alone was
confusing at best and now you know on
the other side of things we have
extraordinary needs plans that should be
probably reviewed and worked through
with the school districts and we just
don't have the capacity to do that staff
so we have kind of maintained this
position
to that we need a position
um to barely be able to implement the
plans if the it is the decision of your
committee to continue to require the
Department of Education to do
accountability plans as part of
extraordinary needs or now some of these
other proposals that are coming over
from House Education
but one option would be to suspend the
plans one auction would be to suspend
the plans the department will support
either one of those positions so send I
can't say that word suspend the plans or
give us a position to do that work
who looks at the once it's done
who looks at it well the department
should but we don't have a staff person
to do that and that person right now
we as we don't have anybody that can do
that work
so we're doing these great plans and I
know and there's no
that's correct okay Mary
and it's my interest in being school
districts aren't real happy about having
to do them either they were not very
happy it was um it wasn't even that they
were happy it was just very confusing
and it was
um a very quick turnaround because so
the the challenge was is that the
Department of Education has to do an
estimate for schools on October 1st and
that October 1st estimate of adequacy or
it's an IU estimate It's the final
calculation includes extraordinary needs
Grant and that is what your tax rate is
set on we give that to dra they take it
and they said the tax rates
then the school district to be eligible
for that had to do extraordinary needs
plan and so they had to tell us whether
they were going to do the plan or not we
gave them past that deadline to do that
um but that was very confusing it was
just an entirely new thing that happened
too quickly
um and the school districts are trying
to wrap their heads around what we were
trying to tell them which didn't make
any sense compared to any other Grant or
anything we received in the best because
there's never been a reporting
requirement required for any funding
that goes for the October 1st tax rate
so quickly so and there was nothing that
came out of the committee of conference
other than our accountability plan was
required
um and the money to establishment had to
develop all the criteria
Etc so it was a hardship for you it's a
hardship for the school districts it was
wonderful money for the communities that
obtained it
um
and we don't even have in the governor's
budget I believe Mickey there isn't
extraordinary
there are extraordinary needs grants
relief funding it is this is bold yeah
and there is in House Bill 2 as well as
uh house bill
638 that we have retained some
modifications to the accountability plan
requirement I sent I think it sets a 50
000 threshold on when they're required
yes yes I remember that so that that's
in House Bill 2 that's in the bill that
we've retained I think even with those
sections passed the department still is
seeking someone to oversee uh I don't
know if you want to speak to the change
that's proposed and helpful too at all
um from the governor's proposal so the
governor's proposal for House Bill 2
actually does include externally so it
the governor's funding proposal
simplifies the adequacy formula um sorry
it's just the account just
accountability well okay so not the
expanding experience or in your news
grants okay um so the one of the things
that we asked is basically a floor for
submitting accountability needs uh
accountability as plans for school
districts so school districts
um if it wasn't you know we didn't know
if it was pal we didn't want to ask the
legislature on our own to remove the
accountability plans we felt that you
guys wrote that into law and you felt
that ex the accountability plans was a
priority for you for you all um when you
put that in
um
so that's why we're saying we need the
support to do this but if you have made
that conclusion on your own great
um
but what we have asked for is at a
minimum if a school is required to do a
plan put a floor in place because we had
schools that did a plan and spent a lot
of Staff hours putting together a plan
for a few thousand dollars and that did
not seem to be a good use of time at the
department especially you had a school
saying I'm only getting fifteen hundred
dollars or I'm getting fifteen thousand
dollars how can I actually really
Implement a plan
um that really makes sense and we said
well there's no floor required so can we
eliminate at least some of these plans
for the school districts that are
they're getting smaller portions of
funding how does it report on so the
report is on the
um performance of the schools so it
looks at each grade level and how the
kids are performing it looks at growth
over time which is how much a kid is
able to grow in a period of time so
you're able to start here and you're
able to get here or you're able to start
here and get here and then achievement
which is a stagnant they're achieving at
this level or they're level one or level
two or things so you're like all right
this is a kid that's always level three
this is how they are or last year the
kid was level two now this year's level
three that means the kid the child has
grown so it looks at different metrics
and it looks at performance and laying
English Math and Science and it looks at
how it looks at we did it based on grade
levels and we broke that down using data
that already exists at the Department of
Education that were required to submit
for other air sorry collect for other
areas of state and federal law and then
we ask school districts how they were
going to
continue to support growth and improve
growth and achievement across those
different grade levels and areas and so
are these for special needs no for all
students yep and they had to select how
they had to create targets so some
school districts set a target of 1 other
school districts send set more lofty
goals but as of right now there's no
requirement for the Department of
Education to kind of review that or talk
to schools or work with schools to say
like this is an achievable goal and
whatnot all right
thank you thank you Caitlin do they have
to tie the dollars to the achievement
because in some places like you said it
was very little but in a place like
Manchester it was I think 4.7 and 2.7
um so so it wasn't we didn't set it up
in a way that was so prescriptive like a
Federal grant where you had to go in and
say I'm going to pay a teacher and the
teacher is specifically going to help
Mentor kids and science whatever
um
but we did say we did have to say our
goal is you know we're going to do
we are going to hire a math teacher or
tutor or to improve math scores so some
high level
um some correlation but not to the
extent that we do for other Grant work
because that's a lot of reporting but
they could probably use some of their
Title One reporting to direct it that
way I suppose
no no probably not because that's just
photography yeah I'd say so title one is
so prescriptive and it's a very strong
supplement not so plants that's a lot of
reporting though for school district yes
it is for a small amount of money even
fifty thousand dollars
yeah I mean we struggled with what is
the appropriate floor and we saw 50 000
it's a round number but I actually think
the cheers idea might be a good one yeah
because it sounds to me and I'll reckon
you just say it sounds to me like it was
a really good idea and I'm sure it had
really good intentions
but if if somebody's doing a report that
nobody looks at it's like why are we
going it's like a merry-go-round you
know what's the point
yeah and and that's why we thought well
the legislature is saying that we this
is a priority so we should just have a
position so we can do that next step
which is look at that report work with
schools to make sure they're
implementing those goals so
but it still sounds to me like
you're doing that anyway
in in some in some realm I mean it's not
like we don't know you don't know what's
going on
all this is a formal
presentation I'm assuming is structured
somehow that you're being asking
what you're asking for is you're asking
to for the people that you're going to
chastise to give you that information to
get chastised
all right so how stupid am I if I'm
gonna give you information to get
chastised you know you follow my logic
it's not
okay it's not working for me
um yeah I wouldn't use chastise well I
would think that we would want to
provide them technical assistance and
professional development around how to
improve their assessments
but but again but the same rules apply
if I
if I have a deficiency
is my inclination to report that
deficiency or try to fix it myself or
you know I'm I'm struggling here well
and the one thing I do just want to
point out is so the intention of the
grant
um was to help school districts with
low free and reduced lunch and high
sorry High free and reduced lunch and
low equalized valuation per student
which doesn't necessarily tie back to
performance on the other side of things
so if you had a grant that looked at
school districts performance and were
obligating funding to school districts
that have poor performance and then
requiring accountability that might make
more sense the Nexus might make a little
bit more sense rather than a more money
for these things over here which and I
mean we certainly have data to look at
the Department of Education at you know
how are the kids How are schools
performing that have high free and
reduced lunch can you know I can looking
at those assessment scores we can
certainly do that work but
um the Nexus between those two maybe not
don't necessarily
this grant specifically don't doesn't
make any sense Dan I think you were next
in the queue yeah I am
I was going to ask two questions uh one
is a very quick and I think it was kind
of already answered the reports are the
same regardless of the you know size of
the correct right so basically every
school larger big has the same forms the
same requirements the only decreasing
complexity for a smaller school is that
they would have fewer kids but the forms
are the same so you know the labor is
comparable obviously that's difficult I
believe I made a remark when we
originally were doing the public hearing
that maybe an accountability plan for a
small amount could be on the back of a
napkin I guess uh no napkins standard
reports yes understood so I think
representative Emrick was getting to
this a little but I want the clear
answer on this
would this funding ever stop being
provided if the accountability plan uh
was not met not talking about reporting
because I can report all day say that
the school says I'm planning to achieve
this goal they don't achieve this goal
and every year they say I want to move
the needle the needle never moves would
that lead to a loss of funding no the
only thing that leads to a loss of
funding is failure to do the report but
the way that it is written into law
right now is performance is not tied to
the ability to receive the funding and
that's the what I'm saying is
performance is not tied to this funding
got it so only the reporting is required
understood so I will say this
the whole offering Gateway based on
performance to the possibility of not
receiving it based on performance is an
amazingly complicated uh issue that I
think we do not want to get into right
now so I'll hold any remarks I may have
had on that for hopefully way later
but the way the accountability reporting
is done right now it's a piece of paper
that you just need to file and mail in
and it has no consequences to me that's
not really accountability reporting and
frankly the way it's implemented right
now I don't think it's a good use of
anybody's time and uh you know
since I don't think that we have the
time and effort to start the Thai
funding to this nor is it something we
should do with you know where we are in
the process I think I'm pretty
comfortable starting to instead of
sticking with a 50 000 floor just saying
you know
Let's uh put this let's let's you know
cancel this and figure it out in the
future on how this would work
my ability is a big conversation now
State our schools are getting they have
an assessment process in schools that
are not achieving to the degree that
they should be usually you need to end
up doing some kind of a plan to bring
the students up so there's already means
in place
that requires some kind of
accountability plan so there are at
least two different kind of Pathways for
accountability reporting right now
around that um so there's the federal
every student succeeds act which
requires the Department of Education to
do a various amount of categorization of
schools and look at the bottom five
percent of schools those bottom five
percent of schools are the comprehensive
support and Improvement schools and
there is additional funding available
sorry the bottom five percent of Title
One schools I do need to add that in
because it is a caveat if you don't
receive Title One funding then you don't
get included in this so there could be
five there could be schools that don't
receive Title One funding they would
otherwise fall into that category
um
so there's additional Federal funding
it's a set aside off the top of our 50
million dollar 40 million dollar a year
Title One Grant
um that we give to those schools they
also then have A needs assessment that
they're required to do they work with
various different contractors that the
department has in place to improve their
assessment scores and whatnot we do
those determinations every three years
we have we did
determinations this past fall and we
will be doing determinations again next
fall just because of some technical
concern not because of basically covet
we got kind of messed up with our
scheduling
um because we had two years that we
didn't really we had assessments but
what not
um
and there's a a lot of metrics and
um that are involved in that calculation
so we do that through our federal
process it's paid for with Federal
funding additionally we do have state
accountability that is required under
RSA 193e and
rsa193h those are accountability for an
adequate education uh the department of
education does have a comprehensive
overhaul of those systems right now that
we've been working we actually just got
passed through Senate education and
we'll be coming to hopefully full Senate
shortly
um where we are not redesigning but
rewriting the existing law in a way that
we can start implementing that work
um so representative Heath and Petrie
and Murray you maybe remember this but
we you did Grant the Department of
Education a position to oversee State
accountability last year specifically
and we're working through those
processes right now that Pro those two
processes are known as the input-based
accountability system and the
performance-based accountability system
the input-based accountability system is
um essentially a survey slash narrative
that school districts must do or schools
rather must do every
um what we're trying to say every three
years because the schedule is kind of
confusing right now
to describe how they are implementing
inadequate education so that's the ibas
system and people have that name means a
lot to an educator they know what the
ibass system is
and then the pbas performance-based
accountability system looks a lot like
the Essa program that I just described
which is the CSI
um this comprehensive support and
Improvement schools where we rank
schools and we look at the bottom five
percent of schools and then there is a
reporting structure that is in state law
that school districts must do reports
for every year that they fail to meet
the definition or fail to show that
they're providing an adequate education
through the definition in state law and
those reporting requirements I forget if
they're an RSA 193e or rsa193h but it
describes some reports that they're
required to do for a series of years
I'll go back to my original observation
even though I I don't know what title
one money is because I'm new to this
yeah well let me tell you let me tell
you so so Title One money
um is money that the department has been
receiving basically for the history of
forever but it most notably became known
as title one under No Child Left Behind
in 2001. it's grants that go to every
single School District it's a formula
allocation Grant I'm sorry every single
state the Department of Education in New
Hampshire receives about 40 million
dollars that we allocate out to schools
on the basis of enrollment and free and
reduced lunch and their census data
um and it's so that's this this formula
that's in federal law and then the
federal law is fairly prescriptive on
what those funds can be spent on
um and so that money goes to all of the
schools across the state um and they use
that
um for
um for those metrics um so it's a series
so when we're talking about
education funding and federal education
law there's some large Federal Acts that
oversee and describe a lot of the work
that we do at the Department of
Education uh there are four specific
ones so there's every student succeeds
act which is No Child Left Behind you
can equate those the yes yeah yes the
original Elementary and secondary
Education Act is the original one that
was passed in 1965.
um it was a LBJ
um and then it has been reauthorized
over the years over the years for some
reason the one that got the most name
and notability was No Child Left Behind
because that's really when it became
looking at accountability and assessment
scores and all of that and then so that
was most recently authorized in 2015 as
every student succeeds act within that
there's about
80-ish million fed of federal dollars
that comes to the Department of
Education that we distribute out to
school districts and that's when we
Title One Is 40 million dollars of that
and that is
um to support students
um that have educated educationally
disadvantaged students
um and so then we have Title II which is
professional development funding that
goes to professional development and can
reduce class size title III which is for
um and sorry title two is about 12
million dollars title III which is about
a million dollars which goes to support
English language Learners title IV which
is a technology Grant is a title for b
and a
um
um b um which is the technology Grant
and then
see is
um before and after school programs and
that's about six million dollars so we
have money that we receive for federal
assessments so that's every the every
student succeeds Act
then we also have another large 50
million dollar a year grant that we
receive that we distribute out to school
districts called idea it's the
individuals with disabilities Education
Act that's special education funding
um and then we have Carl D Carl D
Perkins which is career and Tech
education and then we have adult
education which I think is just called
adult education I don't think it has a
fun name but those are some of the large
Federal programs that we're implementing
at the Department of Education so well
yeah but that's not really an education
it is they would kill me if I said that
yes yes as a freshman I would appreciate
a quick summary maybe a quick written
summary whenever you have time you know
just what you were basically giving
verbally but my note-taking cannot quite
keep up and uh
would it doesn't have to be there and if
there is a location you know I can just
go if it's on a website just uh you know
yeah um I'll see what we can send to you
seriously if it's a URL to an existing
page I'm happy I don't need a special
thing
some of it's on the website but not in
kind of in the fashion that I just sent
to you so um actually what I'm going to
send to you is a page from the federal
organmeki is a page from the federal
budget that kind of shows some of those
yes that's perfect yeah
oh thank you uh equalized valuation and
free reduce you keep mentioning that
do you think equalized valuation will
give you a good measure uh and not worry
about the pre-reduced or do you need
that for federal funding
you know what I'm saying in other words
we're looking for a ratio which you take
the ratio like like Farmington let's say
take take what your equalized valuation
is put it over the state total
equalized evaluation all right and use
that as a measure in other words at some
point you're going to find that you know
one's poverty one's once not I mean it's
you hate to do hard lines
you know because you got a stair step of
fat right
but is that would the feds and we're
trying to figure out matter of fact I'm
thinking of 529 in this in this case so
and you keep mentioning that that uh
this this this ratio that you're talking
about between uh and Freeman reduce
lunch which the counts is which is not
root we're not talking about lunch early
but that's I wish we'd get away from
that but call it something else but what
do you think just the equalized
valuation would give us a
a good measure a measure a measure for
poverty so not necessarily not equalized
valuation on its own I think equalized
valuation does look at a ability to
raise taxes it's a very important
measurement especially since the large
amount of Education funding is being
paid for with property taxes I I believe
um so equalized valuation looks at a
Local's ability to raise taxes
um but if you look at a school district
like Bedford or even I'm not sure if
you'd happen to know windham's off the
top of your mind equalize valuation I'm
guessing because there's a large number
of kids in Windham you probably have a
lower equalized valuation compared to
some towns
and then you have other towns like a
barklett a Lincoln or a Pittsburgh for
example that all have a very high
equalized valuation per student right
but there's not that many students right
but but the students that live there
typically they do have a higher free and
reduced lunch percentage of kids and
that's why I think that's the one of the
things when Senator Hennessey wrote the
extraordinary needs Grant she really
wanted to look at both of those things
together saying like what are the towns
that have both a flow equalized
valuation and a high percentage of free
and reduced lunch she was I think fairly
thoughtful when she she did that because
they
they do need to be looked at together
right well we need to we need to measure
a free reduced
besides the you know the the forms
coming in because it just it's not it's
not working and we're we're trying to
figure that out
um so
so the National Standard actually for
the most part I think is just using the
census data which we have found is
mostly inaccurate when it look when you
look at New Hampshire and that is one of
our challenges and why we have an
alternative authorization in title one
so many states just use the census data
when they're Distributing their Title 1
Formula but for example we have
alternative authorization and approval
from the U.S Department of Education to
use a blending of enrollment for
introduced lunch and census data which
we feel like better gives funding to all
of the districts across the state
so
um so what I just described that's how
we distribute the title one funding yes
that is the blending of those
and this is where we're looking at going
to Medicaid
well so if you use McCade it is just
um if you use Medicaid in direct search
so I
there's I know there's a couple
different proposals and I haven't been
engaged in every conversation
um but if you use
Medicaid in direct serve all it is is
going to include Medicaid as an
eligibility factor for free and reduced
lunch but then all the additional free
and reduced lunch categories will also
be included whereas if you just use
Medicaid instead of free and reduced
lunch you would only be using Medicaid
so there there is a
um
okay speaking for myself we do
understand that the you know legislation
to directly enroll Medicaid kids into
launch may or may not pass and even if
it passes it will only have an impact
here is down the road we were trying to
figure out if there is something we can
address in this budget cycle to address
the concerns about the free and reduced
numbers being inaccurate and resulting
in underfunding of districts that may
need more funds but they just don't have
the fnr because you know the launches
are free anyway so parents don't fill up
the forms so the lunches are not free
anyways anymore well yeah but for a long
time they have been and there is a lot
of inertia and people who haven't filed
for a few years may just not bother and
that's what I have actually I was at a
superintendent's meeting yesterday in
Berlin and I heard specifically that
that now they can't collect the forms
and now the the lunch deaths so yeah so
and because of that there is a concern
among more you know not just me but
other people here are also concerned
that that data is just not very accurate
and it under counts and again it leads
to improper allocation of a that doesn't
go to where it's really needed so one of
the things that we were looking at as a
possibility was to see if we can just
take the you know percentage of the
residents that are on Medicaid as a
proxy for poverty the way free and clear
was supposed to do and we are talking
about you know the left side of the
formula right where we just use the free
and reduced and whether changing the
measure that we use to allocate those
funds would lead to a more Equitable you
know allocation and it's a complex
discussion but I just you know while
you're here obviously we don't have the
numbers right now it's actually
something that we are looking to kind of
look how the changes would go but what
would your thoughts be on that topic so
I mean I think there are a lot of
unknowns and I think without having a
apples to Apple comparison it's very
hard for the Department to speak on it
um because we just don't know exactly
how many of those kids that are coming
over as Medicaid eligible are actually
in schools and whatnot the other thing
too I do just want to bring to the
committee's attention is it doesn't
necessarily solve all of the problems so
you are talking about making this change
for the purpose of adequacy which you
know it's a billion dollars it's the
biggest line item in the state budget is
what matters most and we have the you
know where you guys are making the
decisions on that
um so that is an important factor to get
right in the adequacy formula however
free and reduced lunch is still a
requirement in title one and I don't
know that we could use Medicaid we would
have to apply to the US Department of
Education same with some of the other
grants I understood I was just talking
about our portion of States so I think I
am we understand that you know that is a
number used by a lot of federal staff it
is what it is but we cannot fix that
yeah I mean I think there's just a lot
of implications that are outside of the
adequacy formula too so
they were to adopt the use of
direct certification because it would be
direct it would be to a kid that would
be okay and we could use those
percentages for fnr in the title one and
they would go into the FNS for if you do
direct certification it will go right
into Title One good yes and also the fnr
numbers will you know increase
so it would kind of if Medicaid
certificate direct certification would
be a thing probably we would be much
less concerned about the poor quality of
the current fnr numbers in terms of
being a proxy for you know economically
disadvantaged students
no no it's not for this cycle that's why
we're talking you know disregarding that
because the timing you know well let's
go back to the line item you were
looking at right
no my my thought right now is
we're rewarding people for turning in
and Reporting nobody looks at
that it has a Parallel Group
background in other reports that are
already being done
so for for my money I would suspend this
for this spend the next biennium and
figure out you need to do it because
right now it sounds like it's a lot of
work I don't know what happens to the
money does have this have a budget line
so you just remove the reporting part
this is Mickey please Mickey so so yeah
uh as part of your proposal for House
Bill 2 and Ed funding whatever you do
with the extraordinary needs Grant the
uh reporting the accountability
accountability plans are in here so if
you want to repeal it you can do that or
if you just mentioned suspend it for two
years you could do that too whatever I
it obviously Senator Hennessy put a lot
of thought into it and it made some
sense I I think for for yeah this was I
think a house position in Community
Conference yes this did not was not
included in the Senate password Senator
Hennessey
invented whatever the appropriate term
is the grants themselves did not have
accountability plans tied to the grants
she just thought that the grant itself
was important I got it married up here
well no they they get married up when
the bill itself passed
um so when I think it was in the
committee of conference the house then
put accountability they said well if if
the Senate wants to Grants then we want
accountability plans and so that's how
they got married
um but the original Senate proposal from
Senator Hennessey said we I want to
Target additional funding to
uh communities that have a high free and
reduced lunch and a low equalized
valuation and that's all the Senate
proposals did I agree with her
and so so I would
I only we don't need it
as far as I'm concerned I just yeah I
don't do we eliminate it or would you do
we suspend it that's
what's anybody's thought
oh shoot yes
yes that's I love that that's great
to you yeah right she says it better
than me so we're all in agreement
I
would suggest that if anything repealing
it would send a clear signal that if
anybody feels that this should be in
place they can introduce legislation in
the you know Next Period and have a
better plan or fix it but if we suspend
it we are creating uncertainty because
now it's supposed to come back in two
years and nobody will know whether it's
really coming back or it's going to be
suspended again to me repealing it is a
clear we don't think this should be here
if anybody feels differently you have
plenty of time to pass one through the
house and address whatever we may have
undone but sounds like a motion to me
well emotion it is
right I just need to make note of my own
motion so what I'll do uh because this
is part of a bigger component of the
extraordinary needs grant that we
haven't settled how we're funding
education yet so I'll keep this as the
Committees when we do draft an amendment
at some point to remove the
accountability plans from this okay at
the same time we'll remove this position
request from our working document here
since it wouldn't be needed if you're
going to repeal the accountability plans
and then jumping to our retained bills
House Bill 638 likely the same thing
I'll bump that off here since I think I
have a sense of where the committee
wants to go with an amendment relative
to these yeah just yeah I guess as a
follow-ups is when this came I guess you
know last biennium
um we did not want the plans anyway as I
recall it was not part of the procedure
it came out in the committee of
conference and it was not part of our
the discussions here
I'm trying to master that one I think
the department staff that have been
managing all sorts of fun other words
for it
all right
he gives you another one really really
important for another watch
and I should I should mention the
department is very committed to working
on the state assessment and
accountability portions of and and so
when it won't make it to this committee
because it's uh it does not have a
fiscal note and it does not need a
fiscal note but when the house votes on
that
um it's Senate Bill 266 the department
is going to begin implementing ibas and
pbas and we are going to start really
working on state state accountability
from that perspective so
yeah well I guess it's been a good
morning for you
yeah to go back and say guess what well
it's not a final until it's fun but as
of right now yes this is a good decision
for the Department yes we agree is there
another topic you'd like to discuss
um so there are
um some other kind of
positions that we had asked for for
funding I can explain them
um there's some positions but those
might be better left for next week
potentially when our CFO is going to be
here or I can talk I mean I don't know
if I can explain it but do you have a
preference
I think you could really quickly Caitlyn
probably distinguish the difference
between what we see on row 44 and then
45 46 and 47 are a separate thing I
think just just so the committee
understands what those are and then you
can dive into the details with the
Department next week if you want
62 63.
so I'm I'm on the the money document
right now the the funding document
requests
so online uh
44 through 47 are some changes to what's
budgeted for full and part-time
Personnel in the department so I'll let
Caitlyn explain those
so um you all might be unaware of the
technical aspects of the preparation of
the state budget but it is very
comprehensive
um and so each position is budgeted down
to the exact dollar amount of what this
state anticipates spending for an
employee so when I mentioned I was
working on seven D's in last March
administrative services at that point
Was preparing a document called the 7ax
and that is what goes to
um into your you know thousand page
budget document and every time you're
seeing a class 10 or a class 60 line
that's what that calculation is coming
from administrative services and their
comprehensive report
um and so
um if there are positions that are
incorrect or have been changed and what
not since that time period you end up
with kind of some disconnects so the
department had a few positions that were
Corrections that were identified after a
later a review that were not
characterized at the right level so we
had asked for some additional funding
just to make sure we had enough funding
for our existing positions for example I
had a position that was on the 7ax as a
labor grade 19 but the position is
actually a labor grade 25
so we had to make that correction so
those Corrections that you're seeing
there in 44 are just Corrections that we
have gone through throughout the entire
department related to different
different positions that were not at the
correct labor grades and whatnot
so
it's a it's a general fund increase uh
it's and we could you could do it to to
fill those positions at the
um I think those are yeah I think those
are probably more of a yeah it's a 375
000 general fund yeah well that was just
44 that was just the correction oh yeah
total yes yeah so so those I think we
the department would classify those as
Corrections of existing positions just
funded in this budget at the wrong labor
grade that that they really are at in
reality correct the next set and Caitlyn
can can carry this on I think these are
not quite technical corrections but so
the next set are not technical
Corrections because the majority of
these positions were vacant at the time
of the 7ax being prepared and they've
now since been filled at a certain labor
grade so the way that the state rules
work is is so when administrative
services
does that document if a physician's
vacant they budget it at the lowest
level so this
when we're talking about state employees
classified employees which is the
majority of state employees there's a
class system 1 through 35 and then
within that 1 through 35 there are steps
one through nine and so you get hired
and they'll say all right an
administrator is a labor grade 27 and
that's the appropriate claim so an
administrator at Department of Education
is the same as administrator at
Department of Transportation which is
the same as administrative HHS that's
the whole state classification system
um and then the steps are you move
across the steps over your period of
time that you're employed so you start
on a step one and then you get a step
two in year two and then you get up to a
certain level and then you have two
years before step and then three years
before a step over over the life of an
employee
um so the additions are
um so the way it works is is some when
the administrative Services prepares a
report they do
the lowest step for that employee which
obviously makes sense
um and then they do the basic benefits
package for that employee assuming we
come in and then when you go through the
employment process especially given the
state salaries and whatnot right now a
lot of times we're negotiating with
employees and we end up hiring somebody
at not a step one so for example I have
an administrator that I have hired or he
hasn't accepted the job yet um but this
week and he is an internal state
employee he's a labor grade 27 right now
um actually so he's a labor grade 25
right now the position I'm offering him
is a labor grade 27. he's a 27 step five
my 27 step one which is on this report
right here is budgeted at say let's say
fifty thousand dollars I'm going to he's
going to come in at a labor grade 27.
step three it was a lower labor grade
for him
um but it's the comparable for his
current pay so he's not even really
making getting a raise or anything like
that I mean he's going to be able to
make more over the long-term life of an
estate employee but the state rule says
basically just bring them at the same
level so now I have on my 7ax and
actually I said you know three and five
but it's actually a nine and seven so I
have about a thirty five thousand dollar
difference from where I'm bringing that
person in versus where they're budgeted
additionally he happens to have a family
and so now I have um he was budgeted at
twenty thousand dollars for his family
plan and now it's like the fifty
thousand dollars or whatever for for the
family plan for all the costs of all of
the benefits and everything like that
um so the five six and seven
are kind of cumulative hiring decisions
that the department has made for hiring
people at higher levels um relative to
their steps so that's how you kind of
end up with that so
um at that time we had and this is
probably you're seeing while it seems
like a lot of money 800 and something
thousand dollars over the course of
biennium that's probably 10 ish maybe
15-ish employees across the department
that is probably equating to different
steps and or family plans and whatnot
across several years so
right uh how many how many positions
have you not been able to fill and how
long I know other other uh departments
have you know like they're 20 percent uh
not filled and that's that's a big lapse
um I I don't know that information for
the Department for the Department as a
whole I can um find that out I have a
zero percent vacancy rate in my division
though so
I like to brag about that but I'll find
that as a whole
so I do have a call into the department
to hopefully have them join us Monday at
10. okay to go through so a lot of these
things we can have uh hopefully the
commissioner will join us and their CFO
to get into the details of of these
requests I mean I think you heard um so
last week and I remember
um Melissa white talk about the 58
vacancy rate in special education for
example
um I mean it is I can tell you as a
director at the Department of Education
who has a bunch of employees it is
certainly a challenge to recruit
um I've been trying to recruit Mickey
for years and I just can't get him but
um but it is it is it is absolutely a
challenge to recruit employees at the
Department of Education because it's
while you know if there's this
perception that government jobs are
these safe jobs and they're well paid
and everything like that
there is a big disconnect between what
you can pay somebody in the private
sector versus the Department of
Education or during as the seat as a
whole
um and especially for us
I I have Educators that work for me and
these are people they're administrators
of the Department of Education that
otherwise might be a principal or
assistant superintendent and would make
more in a school district I was myself
just offered a business position at a
school district that gets paid 30 000
more than I get paid right now with a
lot less responsibilities than I
currently have
um so there that is it is something that
we are constantly fighting and it is it
is a challenge yeah but you miss all
this fun I know it's why I said no I
said only if I can still work with the
division two and they said no so
Barry
I understand and it's awful that um
the way the system is I didn't realize I
should have known that that they budget
at the base and then when you hire
somebody which you have to hire somebody
at a higher level because they won't
come take the job otherwise that you we
have to make up that money
um of these
is this an area right now because I
don't want her to lose those employees
um it seems to me I can remember running
around scrambling and looking for money
at the department because of a similar
situation years ago and I used to piece
together people's salaries
um it was
pretty confusing sometimes so can we
just um at this point in time for those
positions she just described could we
it's 800 and
800 and I mean that's it's a lot but
it's also so understandable and I mean
Charlie allenhouse did a great job
describing how horrible the situation is
in the state
um and so Mickey want to maybe to bring
up um I did put some funding in there
for class 50 for some um so that is an
additional increase that we could
probably carve out but one of the things
that I asked for was some additional
class 50 which is the part-time money
um to split when you're talking about
cobbling together I have some federal
employees that I could potentially use
to assist with some general fund
required reporting and so I added
increases in to to do some of that
cobbling
yeah if I may just very quick note
because of the size of the request I
would prefer that we wait until next
week when we hear from the coffee
commissioner CFO and we have the full
membership so that everybody can open I
mean it's just five of us right now and
I can provide a breakdown of these
numbers too so you can see each
accounting unit so a little bit more
detail I think might help I'm asking a
different question if this is happening
in this fiscal year
I don't know what's about about next
yeah this funding Works to me like it's
an operational funding decision made by
the department
rather than extraordinary funding made
by the by the state I'm not getting that
what do you mean yeah online they do the
uh they Department of Education
reshuffles people and dollars regardless
of what the legislature does I don't
know why the legislature is getting
involved with funding these oopses that
are by structure
so essentially what will happen in the
long run is the Department of Education
will have a shortfall in the amount of
appropriation a lot of these shortfalls
are often times taken care of with
chronic vacancies but if we don't have
chronic vacancies then we have
shortfalls in appropriation and so
but it
I guess what I'm saying is it sounds to
me like this is internal policy of the
Department of Education and if they want
to come to the legislature and say
man have we blown it and we need X that
seems like what we get involved in but I
don't know that's exactly what we're
doing right now though this is they're
saying we've flown it and when we have
not blown it but we have hired people
within the steps that were allowed to
hire people but we just because of the
budgeting process and things being
budget a lower level we're saying we
would like to continue to maintain we
need to support our existing staff this
is how much we need to support our
existing staff but this is exactly what
we're we're doing okay then I'll go back
to to whose responsibility is it is it
the executive branch or is it the
legislative branch that fixes this to me
it looks like it's the executive branch
because they've already got an approved
budget for 23. and for us to go meddling
it I I just don't understand this is for
24 and 25. this is to carry them over
into the next biennium right
no oh so this is this is new budget
dollars right right and and it's just
it's really it's the timing of when
those reports were developed so if if
your class 10 or all of these line items
was if HH or HHS Das ran that report
today
the report would have these numbers in
it
but because they ran it in April or
whatever it is that they ran it it just
didn't have these these changes
where I got out of phases you're saying
you're talking to somebody come on board
this week
and I'm in fiscal 23. oh so right well
so yes um but so we're talking about
they're coming on board right now
um in fiscal 23 but I'm saying that
amount what they're budgeted for for 24
and 25 was based on who was there in 20
actually it was in 22 right because that
was the time when the report was run so
that's how it's just it's just a timing
difference of the report okay so during
after a budget's passed uh if positions
were reclassified or someone was hired
at a higher step than it was budgeted
the department could move money around
between Class 10s and you know similar
source of funds from around and then
there's also a state salary and benefit
adjustment fund if if they had to draw
from that what really happens by moving
the money around it would just impact
their laps so say they use
money from a vacant position to pay the
other position at the higher rate just
means they're going to lapse less at the
end of the day what the Department's
coming forward with now is
because we when this budget is built
it's built very specific to every
position so for new positions the
default is a two-person family plan and
step one so if they know now that yeah
that vacant position we have budgeted in
24 25 as a two-person
family or a two-person uh health
insurance plan in step one but we
already know we're going to hire them at
a family plan at a step eight so we know
what's in here Associated for that
position is low
so the department is presenting if you
want to fund them you know so that
that's where we're at and a question for
the CFO and the department when they
come in next week would be you know just
have them on the record for what does
happen in the event that position costs
exceed what we budget
um one of these is federal funds
um
which we don't usually I mean that's not
that's outside our jurisdiction do we
just approve that part of it that we're
at the federal money as opposed to the
general fund no I mean federal funds are
are
um in there too in the budget is just
something that's not typically looked at
and that those are my positions I said
well let's make sure we're appropriating
them at the right level I would probably
just move money in from our contract
line if you weren't to approve it but it
just in the spirit of making sure that
our budget as as accurate as possible we
ask for these funds in this area I guess
I'm asking are there two actions to be
done here because part of it is General
fun and part of it is federal funds does
that require two actions on our part
because they're different
so if the the action is one and then
when I do the data entry into the system
the source of funds will be split as
presented yeah
yeah thank you uh you mentioned when you
move money
uh from on on an unfilled position to to
maybe this petition uh do they have to
go to fiscal and what what's that what's
that that monetary amount that uh they
have to come before fiscal uh one
hundred thousand dollars per year so
anything above that uh they would have
to get fiscal and GNC approval very good
thank you thank you I just have a
comment on the budget processing itself
and you know it's not about you or
anybody else involved in particular
about the process
it's kind of difficult you know I
understand that you uh you know were
asked those positions were unfilled or a
different classes and then things
happened after the budget process
started so now we need to adjust that
data but when we adjust
you know by removing a lot that creates
the ability to say well there are funds
available that we are going to put
somewhere else and then we come back and
ask for more funds in a sense we are
creating an additional you know burden
because had we known at the beginning
that the additional 815k was needed
surely the governor would have put it
here and they would not have spent 8015
somewhere else
so
I know that nobody can quite see the
future but just as a you know thought it
would have been so much better if
somebody would have you know set aside a
reserve because I'm sure he did have
plans to try to hire and you knew that
this may have been possible and as I
said I understand that wasn't
necessarily your decision I'm talking
about a lot of people involved but
it would be nicer if
a bit of allowance for this would have
made earlier in the process because now
at the time when we get the budget we
would have had the ability to cut it
down if it was needed but the other way
around it's a bit harder so of course
we'll you know deal with this
appropriately it's not about the
decision on this 815 just as I said for
the next budget cycle more of a
philosophical thought on how an ideal
process was there is just no mechanism
with their current process to do that
because it is it is allocated at a very
specific individual level it literally
says Caitlyn Davis is going to get a
step at this time and period and budget
fully understood that's why my comment
is on the process itself and on the fact
that had we
had a mechanism like this to say the
department is expecting to fill a few
more positions and you know when you
budget early in the cycle you know you
have time to trim it down later based on
what happened when we are early we have
less information we should have some
leeway Possible only if obviously those
plans were known no it's complicated I'm
not saying there is a clear-cut answer
but I I think at some point if you're
going to enjoy a Charlie Arling house
explanation of the structure of this
system he's very good at it I believe I
will enjoy it I I found his comments
very enjoyable overall he's he's really
good at it
he did it for us
he brought structure
okay anything else um I just so one
thing I actually wanted to see if the
committee had any questions or concerns
on or wanted to have a conversation with
is the movement of the assessment
program to the education trust fund
um it is a decision that we made in
collaboration with the governor's office
and it is we would like to see it stay
there in the education trust fund with
the funding level
um and I just don't know if you want me
to explain that real quick I don't have
I I think it's fine okay
and what's hap what's happening as
you're very well aware is the education
trust fund is wildly over funded and so
our chairman at this point in time all
right our chairman is uh working through
reducing the amount of feed going into
it because once it's in there it can't
be used for General funds and his his
strategy is to reduce the contributions
you know there's a seven there are eight
different
contributing uh
departments or organizations or
he said let's reduce
business profits tax for example
I think the governor's budget had a
reduction uh so like 65 or something so
the idea is to get the education trust
fund back to where it was originally
uh put together was to say that we are
going to fund education but it's true
what it's turned into is the education
slush fund
and so it's nice that every education
stuff can go through there but it's what
it's doing it's robbing general fund uh
to the exclusion of what what should we
do with those funds somewhere else
rather than carrying these balances in
the educational trust fund so
the answer is it's there for now okay
okay and we had moved it in there too
because
um the state assessment is really what
is measure the measurement for when I
was talking about looking at our school
districts and their ability to provide
an adequate education we're using the
state assessment so what we moved into
the education trust fund was only the
portion of the assessments that relate
to the vendor costs of operating the
assessment at the school district so
it's all all of that funding is going to
help school districts assess children
and so that's really what the the
decision was by on behalf of the
department so
I'll just Mr chairman I was just
outlining your strategy of reducing the
inputs to the education press fund so
that it Narrows down
so yeah because the concept and its
Inception is in 2009
yes no 99.
was we have to address the Claremont
decision
that says the state must pay for
education
so
we first sat down and derived what
adequacy was
then we funded it
and so we created the education trust
fund just to cover adequacy as a matter
of fact to cover a little less
because if we made made more
the money was lost for anything else
and we had a budget to come so we'll
make it a little less
so we can add we can add General funds
to it but if it exceeds
what they needed what can we do with the
rest of the money at the time we didn't
have any idea what to do with them
except to give it to education so
I think we need to reduce the inputs to
the education trust fund rather than say
oh we could spend it on this we could
spend it on that we could spend no I
think we need to go back to what was
Inception was
and we still will fund everything else
but we need to do that for the
Court decision we must fund education
so surprisingly people have sued us
under 28a
if some little bit was added to it that
you've got to spend this on
and the decision came back if they gave
you some money and they didn't tell you
exactly where it had to be spent how can
you say that they can't tell you to
spend a little more somewhere else
because they already gave you money
they gave you a billion dollars
so
the idea like
the one with
menstruation products oh we never we
never funded it that wouldn't that
wouldn't hold up
they went to court they'd say wait a
minute how much did they give you but we
wanted another
1500 for this but they gave you 10
million
you couldn't find 1400 into 10 million
this that's the way this this thing kind
of Falls up
well were you objecting to it no no
we're just discussing it and
um yes it's a good time to break for
lunch
so what are we going to do we're gonna
put Assessments in here or just wait
or more she will only take more
flower
being the appointed hour
we have from the governor's office Adam
crapo who's the policy director and the
show is yours at this point
great thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon my name is Adam crapo I'm the
governor's policy director as you just
heard I'm here today to talk to you
about the governor's Innovative
Workforce Development student debt
relief program
as you'll hear from others behind me
there's a critical Workforce shortage
across the state but especially in the
medical professions
in order to attract more medical
professionals we need to do two things
which I think hp2 does decrease barriers
to entry in those professions through
you know licensing reform and Universal
recognition but also to increase the
incentive to work here
hb2 attempts to accomplish both of these
goals by doing uh by targeting student
debt relief for specific Industries
um the Workforce Development student
debt program proposes to provide
targeted student debt relief to the
medical professions Biotech Industry
individuals at the state hospital
Glencliff the veterans home and other
in-demand fields as determined by the
commissioner of business and economic
Affairs in consultation with the
committee established in this bill
this is all accomplished without any
cost to taxpayers and I won't say that
again no cost to taxpayers it's this is
existing funding
as a division of you know of this
committee you might be asking how we're
going to pay for this our plan invests
50 of the revenue the state receives
from the Fidelity 529 plans to go toward
targeted student debt relief for the
industries I mentioned before
um this Revenue would go to the BFA uh
you see we have James key Wallace behind
me
um and they'll be administering the
program I'll turn it over to him in a
few minutes but you know as a condition
of forgiveness students pursuing careers
in New Hampshire in these specific
Fields such as medical fields and some
of those positions within the state will
be able to become debt free after three
years of living here and working for a
New Hampshire employer
all in all this would be the largest
ever ongoing Workforce incentive program
for students uh Student Assistance and
State history
um and I'm happy to take any questions
on this
questions
thank you Mr chair historically These
funds have gone to
um provide scholarships for New
Hampshire students
so you're diverting 50 of those dollars
for this purpose
in a year where we have a surplus
um I just think it would be a great use
of um surplus funds to do this because I
agree with you I think this is an
absolutely essential
um element that we need to look at and
getting employees right now we've had
that conversation with every single
agency we've seen it's been very
difficult to say the least
um a pay raise for state workers is
critical because at least people are
paying more attention to working from
the state before they just turn their
heads because it just doesn't pay they
can make more McDonald's practically
then they they can working for the state
so I agree with you we need to do this
kind of work but I just I am struggling
with using those dollars that come from
the 529 fund
um and um I'm sure later on we can um
we're going to hear from other people I
presume and maybe they can talk about
some of the
ways in which those funds have been used
um so can you just think about other
funds that that might be directed toward
this effort rather than the for the 529
funds thank you representative yet so I
you know I think we have a commonality
in that we agree with the pay increases
in the budget
um
under this plan 40 of the revenue from
the 529 plans would still go toward the
scholarships that you met you mentioned
the unique scholarships
um 50 would go toward student debt
relief and 10 up to 10 would go to the
endowments
um I think currently and Monica will
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
currently I think it's uh third twenty
or thirty percent that go to the
endowments
um so so that's sort of how that's
structured currently I I believe it is
70 that goes to the
um direct scholarships
30 30.
yeah so currently it's 30 uh 30 that
goes to the endowments and 70 right that
goes to the direct scholarships okay
thank you
other questions
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions and for being here
from for being here
um
let us let me say that no cost of the
taxpayers uh it's no new cost to the
taxpayers right at the end of the day
you know there is always a cost but
um my question is on the program
specifically uh you said they will be
debt-free after three years were living
here and working for a employer in
certain fields
I want to understand you know when you
say debt free are we gonna pay the loans
where are what's the source of the loans
that they would be paying and how would
we pay them for example you know do we
just
pay off the balance or do we let it go
because it's from us I would appreciate
some details
so the way the way it's structured
currently in this bill is that the BFA
would after three years of a student
after they graduate they work in a New
Hampshire business and they have to work
there for at least three years and there
are some other qualifying conditions but
they have to be and you know one of the
fields and all of that but after three
years the BFA would provide a a sum to
pay off either the balance or a portion
of the balance
um and really the with this proposal
looks to do is to give the authority to
start creating the program and the BFA
would come back to the fiscal committee
once the program is
fleshed out and and the fiscal committee
would determine whether or not to move
forward with that plan and offer
feedback to that plan
quick follow-up
um I understand that I appreciate it my
other question is about the duration the
three years
I am not an expert in the field but it
feels slightly short I I'm just trying
to understand how the number came up
with what are your thoughts in terms of
whether this is the appropriate length
of time to require them to be here
before this is Forgiven or or paid off
and any thoughts on whether that's the
most uh you know effective
time frame so in the past when we've
presented this proposal I believe it's
been five years
um three years we thought was
um a a sufficient enough time and it's
in line with other
um student debt relief programs uh I
believe it's called the it's called
slurp that's the acronym for it that HHS
um administers
um so it's in line with that that
similar proposal so that's that's where
the three years came from
um but but it would defer on on those
um on how you want to structure the
years you know I think you know in the
past we've been happy with five years
we're okay with three years so
thank you I appreciate
just one more question do you know the
number of New Hampshire college students
that would not get a loan because of
this action
do you mean under the scholarship
program under the current scholarship
program if we move to the your proposal
how many students will not get an award
I don't I don't have that but I'm sure
our state treasurer has has some
information on that my my assumption is
that
um you know currently I think it's uh
1300 1300 that we offer to students up
front for the scholarships but she'll be
able to answer that question for you
I just want to say this is one of the
ways it helps to retain students in the
state of New Hampshire and I believe
that keeping our young people in New
Hampshire is a priority for all of us
thank you
yes I would agree that
um that this does keep students here in
New Hampshire uh under the unique
scholarships however I I will you just
have to say that under the the student
loan forgiveness program we are required
requiring people to stay here as a
condition of of that program so uh while
the current setup does incentivize I
think the the the
proposal would would give a hundred
percent of of those people who would get
those funds to stay here
two things one to clarify
percent is 50 of the money that goes to
scholarships now not 50 of the entire
fund
it's 50 of the seventy percent it's
fifty percent of the entire fund of the
of the FI of the revenue that we receive
from 529 plans
yep
how much is that
currently it is I believe 18 million
dollars our state treasurers here to to
talk about those numbers but I believe
it's 18 million uh it's it depends year
to year based on market dynamics okay
okay I have a question yeah um it's so
it's 50 of the fund the 529 fund and so
would there still be 30 that goes to how
because right now there's a 70 30
percent
mix
what's that going to look like if this
if we go this route correct it will be
at least 50 percent to the student loans
um up to 10 to the endowments and the
rest to
um
to the direct scholarship so up to 50 if
if none goes to the endowments up to 50
to scholarships
and that's the current scholarship
correct uh the other thing can you uh
just limb out a little bit what medical
Fields you're talking about the way so
the way it's structured
um we we have medical professionals and
I we are going to work with the Bia
should this pass to Define that further
but as it's structured right now it says
medical professionals in the bill
um I'm looking at the difference
if someone goes to Dartmouth medical and
becomes a doctor are they part of this
program and their medical fees are
forgiven after three years if they work
at Catholic medical or something or this
more directed because that that's a
rather larger chunk of change than if
you're dealing with uh nursing
staff it would be applicable to to uh
nursing staffing it could be applicable
to to folks that if they go to Dartmouth
could be applicable as long as they're
qualifying under the program and they
work here in the state for at least
three years
so it would be applicable to a medical
doctor
under the under the legislation yes I'm
going to defer uh how how the BFA would
like to structure that
um but but under the bill yes
and and this could apply for
student graduates that come to New
Hampshire
the same not just New Hampshire
residents
that's correct yes if they if a person
comes to New Hampshire and works in the
medical field in a medical field or any
of the qualifying fields for at least
three years then they would be eligible
for this okay
question is Army one of the primary
recipients of this
who
Army
um would they be a recipient of this
uh
I'd have to talk I would have to defer
that question to the to the BFA okay
thank you specifically
right thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here uh do you advertise this out
of state uh to attract uh young people I
mean do we have a budget for that
so the BFA would be administering the
program
um I this I don't think this uh
contemplates a budget to advertise the
program
um but but it would be available to
anybody who wants to to take advantage
of it and it's qualifying under the
under the bill right if but they'd have
to know that it's available I mean you
know this is like like Snoop advertisers
across the country I mean it they get
very good exposure I mean we we need we
need people I mean it's especially
qualified people it'd be uh be great if
we could
I I will leave that to the committee to
decide uh that there's no funding in the
bill currently to advertise it but
um I I would defer to the committee on
on whether they would like whether you
would like to add funding for that
should you pass it
other questions
okay whatever you got next thank you uh
I think James key Wells
would be possible though to hear from
the treasurer first to give us a better
context about what this program is where
the money comes from
if you don't mind are you comfortable
with that yeah I'm comfortable okay sure
certainly
good afternoon Mr chair member so the
committee for the record State Treasurer
Monica mazzapelli
so I just prepare a little handouts so
you can keep in case I forget to say
something but if they're just basic
things that perhaps you want to consider
as you consider this proposal but I'm
just going to go over that if if that's
okay with you in that we give you a
higher higher level overview of what
what are the current program is so
um so as you all know we have um our
fighting program that New Hampshire has
um a very successful program where the
fourth largest in the country and
um that the college tuition savings and
I guess I'll back up for a moment this
literature takes no position and on on
this proposal so I'm just happy to
provide any information you would like
to hear
um so the second ball I just wanted to
mention that um the college tuition
Summit plan advisor commission is the is
a commission that has the oversight of
the plan itself and three scholarship
programs so we've been talking right now
about two scholarship programs that were
initially established with
um is an administrative as an
administrative assessment that is
charged to all fightmen and participants
that have accounts with the New
Hampshire plan and so that charge is is
the money that we collect
um and we in the in the law RSA 630a
establishes the New Hampshire excellence
and higher education trust fund and the
money that we collect is credited to the
fund the law also says that this money
that is collected is to be used for two
Scholars for scholarship and
Scholarships in general to assist New
Hampshire residents while attending New
Hampshire institutions so it's it's
currently the scholarship programs are
meant for New Hampshire residents who
attend New Hampshire institutions
so the two score so so the law allows to
do that and then
um the commission has an insert rules
where two scholarship programs are are
defined and and rules one is called the
unique endowment allocation program and
the other one is called unique annual
allocation program the annual location
program provides direct scholarships to
students and that's something
um the treasury provides money to the to
the institutions and then institutions
go and find students that are eligible
for those scholarships the second
program the endowment allocation program
are essentially monthly grants or
allocations given to
um endowments established by these
institutions their restricted endowments
for this purpose only and the reason for
that program was to create
um that institutions will maintain an
endowment and they will they will
provide scholarships and perpetuity so
there are sort of two two two
um two-way supervised scholarships
um so over the over the years uh in the
past the rule had indicated that eighty
percent of the money collected was going
to go to the endowments because the
purpose I believe the commission wanted
to grow those endowments in the past so
they could just essentially one day be
self-funded it was in 2000 it was in
2021 when the commission and prior to
that they started having discussions
about
maybe not funding so much the endowment
program but starting to provide more
um have more money available for the
annual or direct scholarships so since
since so in 2021 the commission amended
its rules to be able to expand the um
the annual allocation program and to
expand uh to provide greater a higher
amount a war amount and also to increase
the number of students who receive
scholarships so that happened and with
that changing the rules since then the
commission has met and has been able to
increase the awards every year so
essentially in fifth grade 23 is the
first year that the because of the
change in the rules the commission was
able to provide scholarships so just to
give you a little context and and this
is actually I'm in my last second to
last bullet and so fiscal year 23
we anticipated about 6400 students will
receive a unique end of the war and
right now it's a 1300 award and that
goes for a full-time student and is pro
rated for a part-time student
so the total cost right now that we
expect for fiscal year 33 is about 14
million dollars
um we're yet to see the total cost the
schools report to us at the end of the
school year for that and then um the
commission already made projections and
decided the eligibility criteria for
fiscal year 24 and so with um so again
seeing that perhaps they wanted to
increase the award amount the commission
decided to increase the world amount to
fifteen hundred dollars per student and
um and again to provide more Awards so
so the schools
um also the eligibility criteria was
expanded to to have students who have a
higher expected family contribution
amount so with that we expected about
over 10 000 students will be will
benefit from this change and the
projected cost is about 70 million
dollars this is a very rough number this
adjusts projections is we're not sure if
that's going to be what's going to be
needed but as of right now now that's
what we know and it's based on data that
all the colleges and universities have
provided to us so that's sort of the
over you know on overview I wanted to
share with you I'll be happy to answer
any questions you have
questions
yes ma'am
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions
um a couple of questions actually uh
first
this is funded by uh fees based on 529
plans what percentage of the money we
currently hold in New Hampshire 529
plans is held on behalf of New Hampshire
residents versus out-of-state
participants that may find a 529 to be a
good program
our 529 to be a better program than
their states sure thank you for the
question so the plan itself we have
about 21 billion dollars under uh assets
under management so right now New
Hampshire is the fourth largest uh uh
plan and the country and the reason for
that
um is because New Hampshire was one of
the first ones that launched the phyton
plan the college Savings Plan and the
country So that obviously allowed to
gain market share right away and and
since the very beginning uh Fidelity
Investments was um has been the program
manager for that one of the key key
characteristics of this partnership is
where New Hampshire negotiated with
Fidelity and
um New Hampshire is
based on a contractual obligation
Fidelity has a responsibility to market
the New Hampshire plan first
even though they have relationships with
other states so foreign for example they
have relationships with Massachusetts
Delaware Connecticut Arizona but if
someone from California wants an account
with Fidelity Fidelity has the
obligation to say we have a unique
account for you in as an account for New
Hampshire so they that's why New
Hampshire has a lot more accounts that
come from out of state uh participants
so I think part of your question was
about a split between in-state
out-of-state money just total ballpark
so because of the population so through
about three percent of the plan money
even and participants
relates to New Hampshire's New Hampshire
residents
um and it's again it's due to
populations so we have the majority of
the count holders are from California
Texas and again it has to do with
population and it's been pretty
consistent
um over the years thank you I would say
that probably the fact that we are you
know no income tax state has a lot to do
with that too because they don't have to
worry that if they move you know this
would be taxable under other situations
but I do appreciate the background I I
really needed it and the other question
I had you were referring to the expected
family contribution or Mountain as one
of the criteria used in determining
eligibility for direct scholarships I do
remember horror stories from the uh you
know FAFSA application where college
students with a parent that was divorced
and refused to support them were
ineligible for the loans because the
federal government consider that to be
available income even though the parents
were estranged and not providing any
support are you familiar with whether
those types of rules are also applied
the same way to New Hampshire residents
or so when we calculate that do we
account for those types of situations
were on paper there is a parent who has
the resources but because of a divorce
and all that there was no intent to pay
I'm just curious whether we
in terms of the eligibility criteria
um the the commission has the ability to
set certain
um certain components of that criteria
the rest is all established in the rules
so the rules um allow so so so one of
the I guess I'll go back to the criteria
what the commission decides every year
is essentially the amount that will be a
that will be allocated for every
Academic Year right the total amount
that we will be able to provide to
students the other component is the
expected family contribution the award
amount
um the the date of when the FAFSA
deadline the FAFSA can be filed and I
guess all of that affects you know how
many students are
will become a part of the pool of
eligible students
I don't believe where you so so so I
guess try to answer your question that's
what the commission decides the treasury
um what we do is provide the funding to
the institutions and they're the ones
that follow the rules and they're the
ones that include the funding as part of
the financial aid packaging so
um so I'm not as familiar with the
financial financial aid components but
um that doesn't sound familiar thank you
so much I appreciate it
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here
um this you have was there an RFP for
hiring Fidelity and how long is that
contract good for if there is
um so initially there was an RFP with
Fidelity and there was um that contract
I believe was for 15 years then it was
renewed for another I'm going to say 10
years it was in 2017 when
um it was time again to consider the RFP
decision and
um at the time so the control allows for
five year own renewals continues five
every now and at the time the commission
decided to renew for five years the
commission just made the same decision
it was we we had the commission had a
meeting to
um decide whether an RFP was going to be
issued or to to or if they were going to
exercise a five-year renewal
um the commission came to the conclusion
that a five-year no was more appropriate
this time around and that went to
Governor Council they got approved so
now the contract has been extended for
those five years it will expire I
believe in 2020 a
it seems to me if they're out there
selling plans in other states and
putting in our Treasury
to our benefit I should say why leave I
mean you're not going to get a
sweetheart deal like that again
you hope it's locked in yeah other
questions
yes just thank you this has been a
fabulous program for our students and I
just think it was actually what a
brilliant idea of somebody whoever
developed it
um has worked well
well she did a wonderful thing
um so
um we're talking about another much
needed program too but my concern is
what this would do how would it reduce
the number of
scholarship Awards to our New Hampshire
uh students
thank you for the question so with the
funding me introduced to have
um and then the commission has so so
again the the funding that we receive is
really based on the value of the
portfolio right the trust so with the
market expectations and those
projections have been lower a bit and
and so right now we're projected to
receive about 17 million and we just got
the most recent projections from
Fidelity so assuming that we get 70
million dollars for each fiscal year
then we just have half that will be
um four scholarships
um with that half the commission has the
ability to decide how they will use
those those funds whether they want to
continue funding the endowment program
or if they want to do what the new
proposal says up to 10 and then the
other one put the commission based on
the rules has the ability to decide how
much to send to both programs so
um again it will be about
um you know eight million dollars for
the scholarship programs
um perhaps you know um one of the poor
Parts is that since the rules uh were
changed we're just trying to see how the
additional funding is allowing you know
how many more students are being
um will benefit from the you know from
the changes the recent changes made so
we have these projections but unable to
really quantify
um the exact change but um again
assuming so for example I gave you the
cost that is expected for uh fiscal year
24. if those costs are true then
um you know perhaps there will be a
change will be required whether the
Aurora man will have to go back from
1500 to 1300 or something less less
students will be eligible because
perhaps we have to adjust the EFC the
expected family contribution so there
are less students eligible so obviously
some some changes will have to be made
just a quick follow-up in terms of the
commission the 529 commission
um will The Proposal from the governor's
office impact that Commission
uh there are some there are some changes
in the rule that they look like change
I I don't think structurally it doesn't
I don't believe it changes but but it
but there are some changes in the in the
proposal that um they're being mentioned
um just the name and
um there are some um
um clarifications that this bill does
um
you know
I will probably defer to the to the
governor's office to really describe
what those those really mean
okay
the uh speaker's appointment to this
committee which the treasurer is in
charge of as myself and Peter leishman
we're meeting Monday
so
then I also talked with Kathy provencher
you know we're going to look at these
changes and we were never consulted no
were you I don't believe
I was uh I was I had just had
conversations with the governor's office
about
um you know providing information the
current information that is is is is is
exactly what I'm doing today so I will
come back to the committee with comments
that will hear she and I will hear at
that meeting on Monday to see what they
think of these changes and
they may ask us to change it
in which case Peter and I will be more
than willing to see what what we can
bring forward to that I'm not sure
they'll be all accepted because if
there's some thought that we're reducing
the direct scholarships to New Hampshire
students
that may not be as as popular
and I thought we already had a previous
program to give to the people that were
working in the Army I know we had a
previous program some years ago and now
people are being added to it as more
people get added there's less money to
go around so I'm not sure as as that
will be
something they will be willing to do so
we will have that meeting on Monday she
will be in charge of it and
we will come back to you with with
whatever the thoughts are when we bring
those pages from the
hb2
but anyway you will have a conduit thank
you
other question
yeah I'm just trying to work out my road
map so last year
um 14 million was given to uh the
scholarship program
this year the expectation of the the
money that you'll have available is 17
million
and if 50 of that goes to this new
program
that would leave eight and a half
million less than eight and a half
million for the scholarship program
which is close to half of what you gave
away last year
did I follow the dots there correctly
yes but my understanding is a proposal
of the effective date of The Proposal
will be for fiscal year 25 so it doesn't
appear that it won't will impact the
current
um what has been already
granted to the schools and the students
yes that's correct
other questions
just um that it will change the nature
of the 529 program in permanence if we
go this route
the the nature of the scholarships yes
thank you
okay thank you very much thank you
good afternoon uh for the record I'm
James key Wallace I'm the executive
director of New Hampshire's business
Finance Authority thank you for having
me today
um I should say right off the bat like
the state treasurer's office the BFA
does not support or oppose legislation
but we're here as technical advisors to
the legislature and other apparatus
within the state government
um
in this proposed Bill we would
administer the trust that would be
established if the legislature moved
forward with the action
the monies that were being discussed
will be put in a trust held in a
separate account for this purpose along
with any interest earned on that trust
and we would design a program
with all the parameters of how much is
the maximum that would be forgiven you
know how do all the rules work we have
some thoughts on that already I'm happy
to take you through but we would bring
all those ideas to the fiscal committee
which is the same process we had to go
through with the Army student loan
Provisions get approval from the
legislature and then enact the program
so I'm here to both answer any questions
that you might have and I'm also willing
to take you through some of the
mechanics of how the program would be
administered we think if that would be
helpful to the committee
uh thank you
the Army program how many people were
given distributions and what was the
total amount
um it's a good question uh
representative so the Army program
although the bill was passed to create
the student debit the forgiveness
program uh it was never provided any
funding to operate or provide any of the
uh forgiveness until actually quite
recently
um I don't know exactly what it was but
there was a little bit of extra I think
there was a surplus funds conversation
very recently then the last session and
they put a one million dollar allocation
into that program
and so that kicked off us being able to
actually design the parameters of the
program so that's the stage it's in
we're getting ready we hope to bring it
to fiscal soon for their approval so
zero to answer your question directly
that was like five years ago yeah yeah
uh I'm not exactly sure what triggered
the funding into the program just a
number of months ago you might know I I
got the call and uh we went to work and
I think maybe there was a
a period of time that people would have
to keep working before they would even
qualify in other words oh here I am I'm
working for Army I want some forgiveness
on my scholarship okay you have to be
with us a number of years before we're
going to give you any forgiveness
yes representative that's right the
model proposed here is actually very
similar to the model that was passed
with the Army uh you know regenerative
medicine bills in that case it was work
here for five years and then you'd be
eligible forgiveness up to a maximum
amount that would be defined in the
rules which was by the way proposed to
be twenty five thousand dollars at the
time
um this legislation proposes to shorten
the required working window to three
years instead of five years
there had been some feedback that five
years was just a long time to wait to
effectively recruit Workforce and that
given the immediacy of the crisis that a
three-year window would be more
advisable
has anyone filled out paperwork to
qualify yet
not yet no the applications haven't the
window's not open yet we're bringing the
proposed rules to fiscal for their
approval soon and then I know there's
demand people call and ask when it's
going to be ready I guess there was no
good follow-up I haven't heard of the
program since it was past five years ago
it really went dormant until the funding
was made available for it to now enter
the request for funding either
yeah I'm I'm not sure
how it happened uh but was the source
supposed to be at its Inception
General funds okay thank you thank you
Mr chairman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions you just mentioned
that five years is a long time to wait
am I to understand that that means that
the you know
contribution is only given at the very
end of the term so you gotta first go
through five years and then you get a
one-time loan payment yes that's right
representative the payment would come at
the end of a five-year period if you
continue to be eligible uh you're not
actually locked into a particular
employer for those five years as long as
you're working at an employer who's
eligible so if you're a nurse in
hospital one and you switch to a nurse
being at hospital two
you don't get kicked out of the program
as long as you continue to be at what's
defined as an eligible employer so as a
quick follow-up would you because that
is a concern and I agree with you
if for example this program would be you
know the program we are talking about
which is currently proposed for three
years would be extended to five would
you think that if we change or we
suggest a change because I know this is
not our you know daily weight but would
it be effective if you decide to
allocate at least part of the benefit
through the years and then I have a
smaller lump payment at the end I'm just
curious as to various possibilities I do
recognize that that's not the you know
the law that we're discussing does not
specify that but in making the decisions
over the term it's good to know whether
you would have that flexibility to make
it more effective even with a longer
term thank you representative you're
touching on the question that we
actually probably talked about the most
because it's in some ways the most
interesting you know question except for
how do you pay for it right but
um the original thinking which is now
you know is that we would actually pay
down a portion of those student loans a
little bit every year
when you introduce that concept you to
run a good program also need to
introduce a clawback provision of what
if you don't fulfill the term of your
obligation and you and you leave early
you know now you've you know only worked
for here for a year and you've gotten a
big chunk of money and is that really
what we wanted to do
the thinking was no
problem was There's no practical
clawback mechanism the only way to do
that was actually to technically lend it
to the enrollee those Loans pay down
their student loans by a small amount
each year and then you have to enforce
their obligations under the loan
documents to repay you back but it's
governed now now the state is a student
lender fully understood and actually
based on my experience at a town of
Windham I've been the finance director
for six years and a half I find those
types of callbacks to be amazingly
difficult to enforce even when the legal
right is there so I had no thought of a
clawback that's why I was suggesting
that by setting say half of it at the
end and then just making smaller ten
percent payments over five years the
state could argue that you know only the
50 percent was bound by the full five
years and the rest of it was earned as
we go now I'm not sure if the text of
the hb2 has proposed would allow that
but I'm just asking for forget the
legislation I just want to understand
how you would whether you would find
this a more effective method
in terms of addressing some of those
concerns about boy five years is a long
time to wait but if I get 10 percent
every year and then fifty percent after
five would that make the five years
easier to manage sure yeah that's a
great question
um uh the current language in hp2 is
proposed does not allow that
um
paying a little along the way actually
has a tremendous amount of benefits a
surprising amount of benefits because
the way that it would work is an
enrollee is in the program
they have to keep making their payments
throughout the program
and if early on the program say year one
you were to pay down that loan by some
amount and they keep making those
payments more of their own payment is
going to principal and less to interest
and they actually end up paying more of
their own student loan by themselves
because they're not racking up as much
interest along the way and it's it's
quite remarkable how even a little
payment early on can end up it's like
your mortgage right you make an extra
payment early on you're out five years
early right it's that sort of math so
early payments all other things being
equal
are exponentially more attractive to the
enrollees thank you
the original army program went through
the full legislature it was voted on as
a bill
and then I didn't realize it wasn't
funded but now that I see that there's a
five-year requirement I could see why if
this was coming to us merely as the
funding source that would be one thing
but it rearranges everything this
I'm upset at this being just an hb2 and
not presented as a separate bill because
there are some policy changes here that
that probably should have been looked at
the same way the original bill was I'm
going to discuss this anyway with the
with the 529
committee and and because this is being
added to the sections that that we're
dealing with so
it is it is rather unusual to not only
it what was approved by the full
legislature now comes back to us to just
the finance committee to say oh by the
way here's two or three changes in we're
going from five years to three years and
so on and so forth
um it I'm not I'm not comfortable with
it anyway thank you
the question came up earlier about
promoting this
availability
and if people are calling you already it
doesn't sound like promoting it is a big
problem
yes thank you uh Mr chair it's a good
question actually no one has asked it
yet so I was sitting in the back
thinking huh you know
um you know I I can tell you that the
way we envision this is it's this is
really
um a tool for employers to recruit
Workforce so it's not so much the state
going saying hey come to New Hampshire
you know we'll help with student loans
it's really
hey these employers can go to the
workforce and say come work for me in
New Hampshire and we'll help you with
your student loans and so really the
employers it's it's a public-private
partnership the employers would be the
ones who get the word out
um
but whether or not it actually casts the
state in a good light as a whole and
should be promoted actually is I think a
pretty interesting question
another way to look at it back to your
point early payments are very savings
like paid off a
30-year mortgage in seven years with a
couple hundred extra bucks a month and
uh but so by the same token
you give someone a thousand dollars
while they're in college now it saves
three thousand dollars later in
and payments for a tuition loan so we've
got people already paying a tuition loan
are they were they New Hampshire
students which was the whole focus of
this thing anyway or they come from
somewhere else
so it puts a whole new spin on the thing
if I'm looking for where the money gets
me the most Buck it's to give it to the
scholarship to the student now rather
than paying making payments on the
student loans anyway that's
looking at it from the same way you're
looking at it early payments count more
thank you
a quick addition to representative
Wireless comments I agree with you know
most of them but I'm looking at the fact
that we have an obligation to help our
residents absolutely whether they stay
in the state or not I mean they are New
Hampshire children raised by New
Hampshire families so I I'm very happy
with that but I would argue that uh
using a good portion of this to fund
people who then come and live and work
here
maybe uh you know better use of the
money in terms of the overall long-term
benefits for the state because we do
need we are hugely challenged in terms
of Workforce and anything that we can do
to bring people here
I don't think that a lot of people will
stay here for the five years and say
geez you know I've hated this place for
five years but I got my student loans
paid now I can go usually when you're
staying somewhere for five years you are
feeling pretty comfortable and you stay
there so I would really like to see a
balance of the two you know where you
have you know the direct scholarships
and then also this form of uh trying to
uh you know attract the exact type of
employees that we so desperately need in
the state we keep talking about
shortages both for the public and
private sector this seems to be a very
targeted use of funds uh yes thank you
representative and you know again we
don't take positions on the on the bill
I you know the way I read it is it's
trying to do
two things really it's trying to sort of
maintain Workforce Development through a
push strategy right pushing people
through the university system by
offering scholarships because we know if
you graduate here you're more likely to
stay here you're not guaranteed to stay
here but you're more likely to stay here
but it's also adding a pull strategy to
say well let's continue to help people
go to school here and hope they stay at
the same time let's pull people from our
own schools who graduate but also the
best and the brightest from anywhere in
the country right and bring those to our
employers here in our state by offering
loan forgiveness as a tool for those
employers so I think the I think the
policy is trying to say is you know
let's do both right that's how I that's
how I read it I think the question is is
both what the legislature wants to do
you know or how they want to pay for it
then that's the ultimate question
thank you
uh thank you for being here I believe
the goal is the same for the scholarship
program as well as this new program uh
you know we're looking for workers to
work and live here and it it uh you know
it's it's the same goal no matter how we
get there and we've got to remember that
59 of the people live in New Hampshire
were born someplace else so we are an
immigrant State thank you
thank you representative as one of those
I I completely agree I was five I hope I
count as a resident but uh but hey yeah
once you start complaining about
Massachusetts driver
oh and then I think I was I was probably
six when that happened so
or or the people who saw you move in die
yeah yeah
any other questions
okay thank you very much all right thank
you
thank you
okay
yeah
good afternoon members of the committee
so
um Richard lavers Deputy Commissioner at
the New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security and where I got my
director of the economic and labor
market information Bureau the Department
of Employment Security
um so
um we're here just to help provide a
little bit more context uh to the
proposal from the workforce uh
perspective so some of the members might
have attended one of the earlier
sessions that we had uh where we had
provided some information to uh the ways
and means Committees of of both Chambers
I know several of the finance committee
members were in attendance as well where
we had been asked to look at labor force
issues and provide uh our our best
effort at forecasting where the New
Hampshire economy was going
um and either they hated us so much or
they liked us so much they invited us
back uh for for a second session
um and then we even got invited back for
a third session
um Mother Nature got in the way of that
with a snowstorm but we did provide a
significant amount of information with
regard to what we feel is a critical
issue in temperatures Workforce and
overall economy with our health care
Workforce and so the information that
was provided to the house of Ways and
Means Committee is really what we are
delivering here to this Committee in how
it relates to this proposal in hb2
and so we'll we'll walk through some of
this information I'll kick us off and
Brian who who's responsible for the
overwhelming majority of This research
will explain some of the information
but I think what we're looking at and
James key Wallace had indicated a poll
strategy we're also looking at an anchor
strategy right so providing enough
enough of an incentive of once we do
pull you back into the state into our
Workforce that we're keeping you here
and so that's that's a key component of
how we can better incentivize
individuals to stay here to come here to
address some of the critical needs that
we are experiencing I'm sure you're
hearing about from employers and and
constituents in your districts but the
critical issues facing our health care
Employers in the state
um so with that being said when we we
turn to the first page and you can see
here
um
how
each of our employment sectors have
fared when we compare to compare where
they were prior to the pandemic we look
at uh quarter three of calendar year
compared to quarter three of 2022 those
quarters are the the two selected
because we wanted to compare
pre-pandemic and as current as we can
and based off of administrative records
that are filed by employers so these
these are not a survey based numbers
these are based on actual administrative
records as employers file with us
quarterly with their payroll for
unemployment insurance tax purposes so
you can see here overall New Hampshire
New Hampshire's private sector Workforce
has has not only recovered from where
they were prior to the pandemic and the
peak before the pandemic but they've
reached a new Peak so we've we've
recovered quite well from a private
sector jobs private sector payroll
perspective overall
however that recovery has not been
equally felt across all sectors so what
you can see here when we look at the
bottom of this chart is some of our
sectors that are struggling the most in
order to get back to where they were
back in 2019 now
um
two of the the sectors that we've
highlighted and read are our health care
sectors so hospitals and long-term care
employment you can see how far off they
are from where they were prior to the
pandemic state government also a a far
cry from where they were from an
employment perspective prior to the
pandemic when we compare actual payroll
records
now keying in on on the the health care
component of that for purposes of the
the provision in hb2 that that you're
considering we look at the nature of the
decline in our health care sector so
moving to that next slide you can see
the decline in our health care sector is
really in some of our critical nursing
positions
um so
um
the the bottom of this chart you can see
our registered nurses who are the
largest component of uh nursing
occupational positions in the state in
our health care industry
um off significantly
um and our nursing assistants are
licensed nursing assistants lnas off uh
significantly when we look at that
occupational uh decline you have a
question yeah I what you said you
collected that data from employers is
that specific to a zip code employee zip
code
so you know what I mean in other words
try it back to to a certain town so you
can I'm thinking uh
poverty reach here and how we can type
which which I was thinking at before
under Suda I believe it's state
unemployment yeah so the state so the
state unemployment tax act so the the
information that was the basis of that
initial slide where I'd reference can
you get the aggregate of by Town
um what we have there in our uh is our
quarterly census of employment and wages
our qcw program so that's where every
employer who provides employment in New
Hampshire they they file with us a
quarterly report which lists all of
their employees and how much they paid
them during that quarter uh we then
um through uh Brian's Bureau we do
provide
employment statistics drill down to each
Community uh within the state that slide
though was looking at the actual records
as the the employers who are categorized
by the nature of the services or Goods
uh that they're they're producing um and
and they get put into different
um employment sectors that was showing
what their actual wage filings
um demonstrated based on those two
quarters uh follow-up and that is very
accurate information
would you consider a very very accurate
information it's the gold standard of
information that we have thank you
just a quick clarification question that
information though is is it tied to the
zip code of the you know where the
employee employee leaves or to the zip
code of the employer which is what how I
think it is because I filed quite quite
of those quite a lot of those right
because location based location of the
employer because technically you do have
the social security number of every
employee but I don't think you now go
and tight how to tie that way so this
this data is based on people who work in
New Hampshire not necessarily live in
New Hampshire yep just making sure I
correctly understand thank you yeah so
that that program again it's it's the
the quarterly reports filed by the
employers that that provide New
Hampshire employment and they're
required by Statute to report every
employee
um and that the wages in total that they
paid to each of those employees for that
quarter and that's what forms the basis
of how they they pay their their taxes
into the unemployment insurance system
which then supports the trust fund out
of which benefits get paid so that's
that's the the information that we rely
upon
um and and showing that statistic broken
down by employment sector to see how
employers that fit within each one of
those sectors how they've done from a
Workforce perspective and that's based
on how many workers they're reporting to
us they have and comparing that quarter
prior to the pandemic in that most
recent quarter that we have the data
able to be published so that's
trying to answer that question sorry if
we didn't get there in the most direct
route but hopefully we got there
um
in um turning to the the next
um slide
um looking at actual continuing to to
focus in here on on the health care
sector and the and the the difficulties
that Healthcare employers are currently
experiencing
um you can see here what their monthly
posting activity
um looked like for registered nurse
positions that were the subject of a job
posting for New Hampshire employment and
comparing average monthly posting totals
for the 2018
compared to 2022 and we also do hires as
well again this is just solely looking
at registered nurses but I think if you
if you talk with your with the
healthcare employers within your
districts they'll tell you that 2018 was
difficult they were struggling to fill
positions back prior to the pandemic and
you can see what the posting activity
has actually done over the course of
comparing those two years and the demand
has increased significantly particularly
for our registered nurses and the the
actual hires the average monthly hires
have actually increased significantly as
well when you compare 2018 uh to 2022
um
question that's a quick question
um pertaining to the job openings are
these new openings or these openings
because people have left it's a
combination
It's a combination there's a lot of
churn in the in that market we have a
whole presentation on
um issues related to health care uh
Workforce and one of the things
particular to the registered nurses that
we didn't put in this presentation but
the fact that there's much greater
competition for registered nurses coming
not only from hospitals and and nursing
and Residential Care Facilities but also
from other Industries we know that the
retail industry for instance the Walmart
CVS targets are opening Health Care some
sort of Health Care Facilities they
become attractive places to work for
many of these individuals so there's
increasing competition there and there
was following the pandemic a fair amount
of people who left the profession so
there's been a lot of churn in and one
of the biggest sources of competition is
from
employment agencies that hire nurses for
traveling as traveling nurses a big
issue and the wage differential there
may be three times what they might make
working at a hospital so there's a whole
host of things that are contributing to
that elevation of the uh of the job
openings
would you say that the impact of the
shift to traveling nurses is more of a
temporary shift due to the pandemic and
we expect to see stuff coming back to
more or do you feel it's a permanent
Trend now that the pandemic opened the
flood gates because it seems very
difficult to justify as an employer
paying somebody three times more to hire
them as a temporary person so I'm just
trying to understand what are your
thoughts on the you know the the reality
is I think in talking to some employers
hospitals in particular is that they
don't have a choice if they want to
provide the care they have to they have
to have the nurses in order to provide
the care so they will do what they have
to do in order to get that Staffing and
that means hiring a temporary or a
traveling nurse at three times so
um and from a nurse's perspective it's
got to be very difficult to give up that
increase in wages so
it's kind of a spy it's a kind of a
spiraling effect and it's an arms race
um you need the you need the staff they
want the money and at some point
something has gotta Gotta Give there I I
I can understand that as at this point
in time but again in the long term that
does not seem to be sustainable because
of that huge gap you would expect
employers to start increasing wages to
get somebody you know as a full-time but
still not pay anywhere near the uh
that's why I was asking more of a long
term what kind of shifts do you expect
because it does impact how this issue
one of the issues that complicates it
particularly for hospitals one of the
industries that saw the biggest decline
where ambulatory Ambulatory Care
Facilities didn't see that decline one
of the big differences between hospitals
and nursing and Residential Care
Facilities as opposed to Ambulatory Care
is their patience and who's dependent on
Medicaid so hospitals a lot of our
hospitals have an obligation to provide
care they provide a greater percentage
of care to Medicaid recipients so their
revenue is a is a little bit more
constrained so they have a difficulty in
raising their wages in the same way that
say a staffing agency who can then hire
out that that individual so there's a
lot of complicating issues involved in
this I appreciate I appreciate the
Insight it's very uh educational thank
you I agree it is really a critical need
my question is insurance companies are
making millions and millions of dollars
why don't they fund this process and not
take it away from our college students
I'm sorry to do that to you I apologize
but I couldn't contain myself is there
an insurance lobbyist
and and representative we get to we get
to provide you more information to make
to make what we hope are better
decisions but we'll leave those policy
decisions to you
but it just continuing on on some of the
when we try to really Define the problem
and we're working with some Health Care
Workforce
um initiatives in the state so we're
really trying to
find out exactly what the issue is
because if we just say there's a problem
with the workforce and health care it's
pretty nebulous we don't know what to do
so we've really narrowed it down more
toward the biggest issue is on in the
nursing side problem everywhere but
nurses is seems to be the most
problematic one issue related to that is
the fact on the next chart is that we
lose a lot of nurses who commute out of
state they commute out of state in
particular to Massachusetts Rockingham
County loses on a daily basis about 1200
registered nurses in commute
Massachusetts question
um there there's one County in New
Hampshire that sees an influx and that's
Grafton County largely related to
Dartmouth Mary Hitchcock
um so that's very problematic and one of
the reasons why we believe that's so
problematic is the next slide which is
the wage differential
um this is shows wages median earnings
at the 10th the 25th percentile the
median 75th and 90th so
nurses when they come out of school it's
generally not a big difference between
Massachusetts and New Hampshire but as
they become more experienced they have
more more time in the profession the
wage differential gets dramatically
different so uh basically equal at the
10th percentile individuals starting out
but almost fifty thousand dollars when
you get the most experience so it
becomes a real
um compelling economic uh argument for
many of those individuals to work out of
state
do you have an idea why because we're
talking mostly private employers if we
were talking about government you know
employees I would totally uh see a
difference in philosophy between
Massachusetts and New Hampshire but
since those are private employers is is
it coming back to the same Medicaid does
you know why do you think this Gap
exists because of some of it is cost of
living but it seems too big for that
yeah I mean this is not unique to this
profession I would say
um in looking at waste differentials
between New Hampshire and Massachusetts
uh this is one of the more substantial
differences and I think some of it has
to do with the many opportunities and
the greater particularly the Greater
Boston metro area you know it is a it is
one of the centers for health care
services in the world so there's many
more opportunities some of the best
hospitals are are in the Boston metro
area so I think that contributes their
revenues I'm sure are you know more
substantial there probably initially
there was a lot of thinking that it is
cheaper to live in New Hampshire it is
cheaper to live in New Hampshire than it
is to live in Massachusetts but that Gap
has narrowed dramatically
um and and I and the next chart I just
tried to adjust that median wage or cost
of living so you see median annual wages
for registered nurses if you just take
the the nominal wage pretty substantial
000 difference you just for cost of
living between the two states that Gap
Narrows pretty substantially
but on the far bars the far ones there
is what happens if you live in New
Hampshire and you work in Massachusetts
as a registered nurse then the then it
becomes very compelling then it's a
um you know that's the that's the The
Sweet Spot if you want to maximize your
spendable income or by reducing your
cost of living and maximizing your
earnings
um and there's no incentive which is the
blue line for somebody in Massachusetts
to work in New Hampshire to live in
Massachusetts and work in New Hampshire
which though which leads to my the
question that I was asking the chair for
if those people are people who moved to
the Greater Boston area because of jobs
in Boston and they just choose to live
in New Hampshire because frankly besides
the financial impact I can assure you
that when I moved from Massachusetts to
New Hampshire it was not just costly
living okay well keep it a political and
leave it at that but
this being said
is there any amount of money that we can
offer them to actually work in New
Hampshire when they came for Boston they
want to work in Boston they just commute
there I I'm just trying to understand
how much we can benefit and how much can
we expect to return because that whole
everybody wants to work in Cambridge
same thing happens with biotechs my wife
is in biotech you cannot start a biotech
outside of Cambridge because everybody's
already there and it's it's a huge
self-reinforcing effect how much of that
applies to the healthcare industry and
how much can we actually change those
decisions in our favor well I think this
proposal is one effort to do that and if
I can take you through a couple of
slides we'll try to answer something
because that that's one of the things
how much will this make a difference or
conceivably could it make a difference
so the next chart has a slide that shows
that the median debt for graduates from
nursing programs that I I picked as many
colleges in New Hampshire that actually
I could fit on this conveniently there's
actually more collagens that offer but
there's a fairly narrow range in terms
of the average or the median debt of
that somebody who graduates with either
an Associates or a bachelor's degree so
that's not including any debt that they
may have incurred at a previous school
if they switch schools it's just the
debt from and it doesn't include any
non-federal debt so private loans not
included here so they may have
additional debt
so that's what we're looking at in terms
of individuals so let's take a look at
what happens get back if I may get back
to your previous slide we're uh we're
talking about the migration or the
working in Massachusetts do you see a
trend coming our way at all no or is it
getting worse I think I've seen a I
think it was 102 000 people a day across
the border to work across borders yeah
uh you know that's been fairly
consistent with
um the number who commute to
Massachusetts from New Hampshire we do
receive a small numbers from Vermont and
Maine who commute into New Hampshire but
on net there's about 40 000 who commute
in from Massachusetts and about a
hundred thousand who commute out so we
we're a net exporter of Labor so it's
forty thousand net yeah we're a net
exporter of labor but and this
particular occupation and if you if you
look at different occupations this is an
occupant one where we are a net exporter
of of of nurses to Massachusetts
Massachusetts Imports nurses from a lot
of places by the way on a daily basis
about 3 600 nurses who live outside of
Massachusetts commute into Massachusetts
for work so they are a draw and that's
our that's a competition because we're a
regional labor market and I can tell you
uh I had a person that was in a
Massachusetts
and uh one nurse was covering three
floors and I mean she was right out
straight I mean it it was unbelievable
so I mean it's it's a problem everywhere
I guess
so
um let's just take one and it's kind of
exactly how this would play out in terms
of making or helping to adjust that
differential so we have the median
annual earnings six seventy six thousand
nine hundred versus ninety one thousand
when it's adjusted for cost of living
this is you have 63 it gets narrowed so
what happens if loan forgiveness that
kind of the average or median level of
debt 27.5 or so the median level of debt
and assume as I did there's a lot of
assumptions here 10-year payback period
six percent interest rate that equals
305 dollars a month so just add that
back in I mean they're not getting that
money per se but if they're avoiding
having to pay that that equals 30
six thousand thirty six hundred dollars
a year so we kind of add that back into
their um you know the equation and it
Narrows that differential pretty
significantly the other way you could
look at it is after three years you get
a lump sum payment they've paid off lump
sum payment it would equal 21
000.50
so
is Eric obviously we're in competition
with these other states is there a plan
like this in Massachusetts
to attract our our Workforce we don't
need it well I mean but it no but it it
you know we're we're going back and
forth here I mean this is a big problem
I mean there's no there's no kids being
born so that's what you get I mean we're
we've lost uh what 221 160 uh 160 000 uh
public school students and I mean you
you see the trend and it's not not good
um and I I know that uh um the
governor's office had looked at has
looked at that I'm going to deferred to
to Adam crapo on that I'm not aware of
any
programs over there I I couldn't
identify it doesn't mean there aren't
any good night
specifically for this
okay so so I think our our
um objective here was we wanted to share
the the additional information that we
had provided to your colleagues on the
Ways and Means Committee
um that that
pinpoint the or try to help better
understand the issues that our
Healthcare employers are are talking to
all of us about
um and
also demonstrating
what can happen when you create some
incentives like that proposed here in
hb2 with the student loan debt relief
when you create some incentives that can
differentiate
the state amongst our neighbors and
trying to keep some of those nurses that
were that we're losing right now
particularly from Rockingham County that
are traveling to Massachusetts to work
trying to keep them here trying to pull
in others and trying to keep them here
so hopefully the information was helpful
all right thank you and thank you that
was really good um but I'd like to know
if I could hear from um Deb scary who's
the executive director of um the uh
before you go I have one one oh okay I'm
sorry
yeah this is a little tangential but
you're talking about you know the
competition around this and there was a
um a move towards I guess Boutique
Medical Care
um is that and the numbers must be small
but do you see that growing or is that
kind of fading away
um with Boutique Medical Care
um if you're referring to more of the
kind of the ambulatory care so
ambulatory surgical centers
um they've from a conductor offices yeah
from from a Workforce perspective
Ambulatory Care grown significantly
um you know they're up 1100 employees
compared to pre-pandemic when your your
Hospital's in your long-term care are
each down about 1100 down 1300
respectively so Ambulatory Care is doing
is in a much different position from a
Workforce perspective yeah so that's
good for them not so good for public
health I guess I could say
not-for-profit hospitals probably
struggle most with that issue
because a lot of their revenue has been
siphoned they have an obligation for uh
to provide care and so it becomes
problematic we brought we kind of
control the certificate of need process
that was preventing ambulatory surgical
centers they would they were clamping
down on them and we kind of stopped them
from doing that
just a quick follow-up since
representative Murray brought the
thought to my mind when she asked about
Boutique stuff
um On a related topic uh there is there
is a topic that keeps coming up about
direct contribution you know uh medical
doctors that don't build insurance but
the patients build them directly and
then deal with that do we see any of
that if so does it have any uh impact on
the employment Market as a whole or is
it too small of a factor right now to be
visible to you guys
there are practices where you know
instead of charging Insurance the doctor
gets paid directly and they say look you
know those are my fees I'm not even
going to bother with the insurance it's
a small but there is demand for it I was
just curious if you see an impact from
that yeah that's not something that we
in the employment data that we have
would be able to discern that we we can
certainly get an idea about the boutique
providers but in terms of their their
payment and and their in their payment
processes we really don't have any data
on that thank you I'm going to share an
interesting I didn't know that uh that
we found out from the community college
uh Chancellor that you can get your
nursing license in two years
through the community college and I said
to him why aren't you promoting that
my goodness I could go out and get a 70
000 a year job with a two-year with a
two-year degree yeah who knew yeah so I
I'm all done I'll get off my soapbox and
it looks like the day that I've I've
looked at
um community colleges are producing
maybe 120 or so two-year nursing on an
annual basis which isn't a huge number
when you consider all of the the
different communities
yeah
yeah so obviously there is capacity
there yeah to provide at the right price
yeah and you see the the growing demand
obviously is there and that's and that's
and the the on the demand side that
those numbers are taken from
um you know that's looking at all
postings for New Hampshire employment
and looking at that growth so the demand
for that that registered nurse with that
two-year degree is right up there
significantly increased over where it
was prior to the pandemic okay thank you
very much
again
thank you
good afternoon everyone um my name is
Debbie scary I'm the president of the
New Hampshire college and university
Council I also serve
um on the unique commission
um and uh as has been previously stated
we'll be getting together on Monday to
talk a little bit about
um all of the of what's in front of us
today for sure I really want to thank
you for the opportunity
um to share um our thoughts on the
proposed changes to the unique plan
um as you know this proposes major
changes to the unique program and uh you
know that the fees that have been
generated to support this program as we
discussed do vary from year to year but
this would be a Major Impact what we
have proposed
um just thinking a little bit about the
commission it's been around in the
program but it's been around since 1997.
um which has representatives from both
the Senate and the house administers the
program
um that we've been talking about we've
referred to it as the endowment program
just to be really clear that is a
campus-based restricted scholarship fund
that only can be used for scholarships
and also the direct funds as well 100
percent of funds have been used
specifically for student scholarships up
until this point
um students will receive these
particular scholarships are not required
to repay them this is pure Aid to New
Hampshire needs students and their
families these are not loans and these
scholarships May mean the difference
between a student heading to college or
deciding he or she simply can't afford
the expense
it is tremendously successful program to
date has dispersed 186 million dollars
in scholarship funds again to our
neediest students and I think we talked
a little bit earlier about the extent to
which programs like this help to retain
students in New Hampshire because these
are for New Hampshire students
over the years there's been strong
bipartisan support for The Unique
scholarship program and the legislature
has consistently turned back efforts to
redirect These funds for other purposes
while student debt assistance is an
important objective and I think the
folks that have been here today have
laid out a really good case it just
should not come at the expense of
student scholarships and for every
million dollars taken from the existing
program we think maybe up to a thousand
scholarships to New Hampshire students
will be lost
we've heard New Hampshire Business
Leaders and certainly this committee as
well discuss the need for well-educated
Workforce and the vast majority of
high-paying jobs in our states will
require a degree so the fact that we're
considering taking away money from
scholarships for students to earn a
college degree to effectively pay for
loans later on
makes questionable public policy in some
unintended consequences for sure
this change would result in the loss of
millions of dollars in student
scholarships for the most financially
vulnerable New Hampshire families and
according to the National Association of
State student grant and aid programs New
Hampshire ranks at the bottom for
tuition aid for our students so there is
it's not that there are other funds
available for student scholarships when
calculating this we're talking about the
grant dollar amounts per population and
just for example the state of Vermont
ranks number 20 Maine is 40 and I think
I mentioned we're 50.
um the unique scholarship plan is the
only long-term scholarship program that
exists in the state with a long
established record of success assisting
New Hampshire students and their
families and I'd be very happy to answer
any questions if you have any
for me
it's Friday afternoon too so I
understand
today's Friday
I've been thinking it has been all week
other questions
Mary can I just say thank you oh you're
so welcome we share a passion for Unique
over the years we've
um
we've gone through these different
iterations that have come to us and I
just thank you for what you do and what
this means to the colleges in our state
and the students in our state because it
has made a difference in um
I have no qualms with the need that we
have it's absolutely but I just
it's how do we take money away from our
students
um and I know this is a very desperate
Health Care is it's desperate
um our Nursing Home in Hillsborough
County
um we are short staffed so we um we have
to close beds in our nursing homes
because we can't staff them and it's
awful for everyone
um but I just don't think this is a
solution and you know I think our
community colleges are doing a yeoman's
job I think all our College of as have
started some kind of a program their
articulation pro programs everywhere
it's how do we recruit enough and you
know good pay probably is one of the
biggest pieces that we could do but you
know it's just
I have to stand with unique as it is
um as much as I know and feel the need I
see the need
um hear the need constantly I just don't
feel that this is the appropriate
funding source I'd love to see another
funding source because I really and
truly believe we need to do something
desperately but I thank you for being
here and kind of giving your history
um and the treasurer what what this has
done and I know our our chairman over
here for finance knows well what fine
521 529 has done for so many children
across our state
thank you thank you for having me
yeah actually two one of them is I'm uh
thank you for the question and thank you
for answering them
I'm a freshman can you just give me a
brief background on you know the New
Hampshire college and university Council
it's just I I haven't bumped into your
organization yet absolutely so the New
Hampshire College University Council has
been around for about 60 years and uh
it's a membership organization of the
colleges and universities here in New
Hampshire we actually think we're one of
the only ones in the state that have
both the publics and the privates
um under one membership
um
so that's basically we do a lot of work
around advocacy
um you know is we are discussing here
certainly
um we do a lot of uh looking at how
better to reduce uh costs by our
libraries work together and making joint
purchases we do a lot of collaborative
programming
I appreciate it and my you know more
substantial question was if I understood
the presentation correctly this amount
available for the direct scholarships
has just been increased in 21. you're
talking about long track record of
success you know
can you speak on what you think the
appropriate level of support for it is I
mean it was successful before it got a
huge funding increase and you know I'm
just trying to understand if you have a
measure on what would be an appropriate
level of funding here
so I think
um the commission has done a great job
with the money that it's been working
with and the and as we have said up
until this point 100 of the money that's
gone from the unique funds have gone to
scholarships and that's been you know 17
18 million dollars depending on the year
so I guess I I'm sort of a historian on
that one and I would like to see that
history continue and again totally agree
that there is a need for the kinds of
strategy to address some of the other
pieces that we've been talking about
here this afternoon which is really hope
it wouldn't be from the unique funds
thank you thank you
thank you Mr Cameron thank you for being
here
um don't you think that this is going
for the same goal of a productive
Workforce or helps to that end I mean
whether it's a student in this pathway
or that pathway I mean it's the ultimate
goal is a productive Workforce that's
true
um but what I I guess my the way I would
look at this would be that we need to
make sure that we're providing
the opportunity and access for all
students to take advantage of a college
education that's the long term and then
we know that many of if not all of the
jobs that are high paying uh do require
post-secondary education of some sort so
it's almost I to me it's we need to
provide that opportunity first without
that then we if we don't get students
into college right then how do we
actually have that educated for us I
think ideally we would do both
right
the questions
yes thank you very much thank you
Mary who would you like next
who would you like next
so who would be up next
I've been
okay with the governor's office
for the policy director
yeah sorry
so is there anyone else here that would
like to speak on this topic
okay
well seeing none thank you for coming
and we'll we'll talk Among Us ourselves
try to
but
thank you
[Music]
we'll get into school
we're here to reduce the traffic on 90
series
if
that happened to me
good thing I was a jerk because I would
be dead today oh really
and I was in the hall that put me in the
hall well
the doctor was mad
you got something else for us
okay
well Republican
no I think that was more because I think
we're going to have to either reconvene
for everybody
or
thank you
oh good I'm glad they're all solved now
Mick you got something
so I have a couple of things I think we
can cover uh
easy things
so if everyone has their binder clipped
packet that I passed out this morning
dated 310
310 yes March 10th yeah 23rd
okay
so you can see I've I've filled in some
of the columns of some of the sections
that we agreed upon uh to this point uh
one that I've kind of skipped over
that's a I think a pretty easy one is uh
page 20 section 51 the repeal of the
advanced manufacturing education
advisory Council this is a for lack of a
better phrase a defunct Council that I
don't think's met for quite some time
and this was really just a repealing an
old Council and a dedicated fund there's
no money in it I've confirmed with the
Department that other entities since
they that met last have kind of taken
over the work that that
council did do so it was duplicative so
that's why the governor had their repeal
in here so you could be okay and accept
that if you wanted to second by Marriott
yeah so the house bill 2 repeals that
you would just say yep that's good
everybody in favor
all right unanimous okay I'm I suspect
we're probably not in a position to do
anything with the sections we just had
the work session on
you want to hold off that for now
or I I I don't know I that's the next
grouping of uh
of sections that we have heard from
folks but we just heard from them so I'm
not sure if
you're in a position or not
yeah I'm maybe after Monday so we can
hold that until after that meeting
three of us here
in myself
but
the last chat that's bar chart showed us
was okay if we give them
okay
didn't seem to make a big difference
if we give 2500 a year
Alex
what their what their own businesses
it's not enough
well I I think I think your meeting on
Monday will probably shed more light on
this yeah
Monday up front
is a lot better than money
on a bone that you pay an entrance and
all that so
and that is it's a thousand dollars
scholarship I think worth three thousand
dollars
reducing your loan
wow that's all
that's kind of a telling point to me
the effects money
thank you Mr chairman I was going to ask
representative Weiler when you go there
to you know look more into that because
I think that's a good policy if we could
agree on it but it would be good because
he didn't go through the Full House and
the policy committees and all that to
get as close as we can to a policy
committee from your meeting on that and
understand whether those types of
changes would be beneficial to me they
look beneficial but I'm one person you
know so
any feedback on that because I you know
it's good to have some benefits
immediately but I still have a carrot at
the end so maybe making 50 at the end
and then ten percent over five years
would be a good structure
foreign
still every little bit helps
scholarship wow that sort of money
we're talking about trying to screen to
work here
and I agree with with Believe It or Not
representative Weiler on this I think
I'm pretty so new I can do that and you
can agree with me sometimes too but I
mean just that that that philosophy of
that money up front just making such a
big difference and I support the concept
of this and it seems to me that this is
it's a new program and if they're
possible to find funding for it from
another source other than unique I would
be very happy for that I think that has
value
um but and yeah I can see the reason for
going from five years to three years but
apropos what you had just said when
you're starting out and you're sort of
gaining experience and gaining you're
moving a lot and it's even unreasonable
I think with its generation to stay any
place for three years and so they're not
going to get any benefit out of this
some of them will get no benefit out of
this at all but they will get a benefit
out of the unique money the one thought
I'd like to share on that
I do think that this is a good concept
and if there are considerations in terms
of the amounts I would suggest that it
may be good policy to keep it but just
shift around some of those percentages
instead of moving that much but I really
believe that this is an idea that has a
lot of Merit there are potential
difficulties and questions over how
effective it will be but honestly we can
speculate here as much as we want until
we try it and we can measure the results
we won't know so maybe we can just shift
around some of the funds find it at a
lesser level but still create it and
test it out to see
if we went along with some of the
governor's thoughts but reduce that
amount of money and say the money we're
already giving away on on scholarships
we should increase by 10 percent
then we'll see what's left
and so on I mean you know then maybe we
throw a little money at this other
concept but you know I don't know if
it's enough to make any difference in
time will tell or take the difference
between the 14 and the 17.
is operating on a 14 million dollar
budget forecast to be a 17 million
dollar budget take the Delta and apply
to the governor's program one one quick
subject yes in regards to that Army
program that only got a meal
I would argue too that a million for
that seems to be rather low and maybe we
can
find a way to increase that a little
because that is a program that appears
to have been uh you know a stepchild it
was created and never funded and and to
me that's something that a meal may not
make much of a difference I think maybe
we could just find a little bit
somewhere to I I said somewhere I was
not specific okay it's always up to the
employer
set it up all right if you come to me
work for me I'm going to start paying on
your college tuition loans not only will
I give you a decent raise but this
little five or six I say eight percent
I'm also going to spend toward your
tuition poll uh your tuition loan yeah
and you know it's always something the
employer could do yeah and maybe he
could go to the and they do some do yeah
the bank and make a deal right yeah and
to representative Heat this is a 529
funded thing it should be used for
education I wasn't really going towards
the Army for that one but since the
program came up in the discussions I
think it's something that we should make
an effort to find a little bit more for
whoops
we are swimming
just the statement is how much do are we
spending
millions of dollars about 35 Grand per
employee
um but then there are people regular
people who are paying insurance
they're making Stout the CEOs of those
companies are making and accept that 20
million 100 million and
we're struggling to get
help in terms of the medical field
doctors it's not just nurses that
started the whole Medical Professional
people
in other countries they take production
to go to school here we go do that and
we're short especially in the world it's
up north and in Texas to the very
difficult situation 10 minutes to think
about all the money that they're making
and there's no efforts to come
stabilize into that well that's why both
the state and my County are self-insured
and you know in your city why should we
make billionaires out of insurance
companies we have enough cash
flows yeah
you can say we can put so much in this
thing and obviously
you know we'll have sometimes that in
the process a little more but we'll kind
of push it and I remember somebody that
was in the insurance said we need about
10 year
what have you paid in one year you need
to help three Michaels 10-year push but
you will have a catastrop here
I mean I've been around for a long time
it's like
somebody's benefits
so we'll we'll move on from there
um all the other sections here at this
point are either ccs and H dual and
concurrent enrollment and the retirement
system provision UNH the
interoperability lab uh and Whittemore
Center
Doe
this scholarship a unique thing we
talked about that one pending dot right
away relative to Prime Wetlands we're
waiting on additional information we
held up on that section
and uh that's that's it so I have the
Department of Education coming to see us
on Monday morning at 10. uh I will have
a work session until you need to take a
lunch break before the public hearing it
too
um as long as you want to meet we can
roll through things uh
so uh in the governor's recommended
budget there's 2 million a year for dual
and concurrent enrollment House Ed and
the house passed a bill that made it
3.25 million per year and increase the
amount of courses from two to five the
governor went from two to three so and
the bill that came over House Bill 420
aligns with what the community college
system did request to do that full
request it would be two and a half
million dollars over the biennium above
and beyond the governor's budget
oh I'll still support twice 4 20.
uh pretty I think it was 20 to nothing
out of education and then a Voice vote
perhaps
yeah
I feel like it was a let me double check
19-1 excuse me and then a Voice vote
maybe even some Democrats
thank you very much
paying good attention to every word
going to get them all out of the public
schools
especially in Manchester
anyway I think we should add the money I
think that's that's a good place to add
a little bit you know we can't keep
standing up and we have some money
we'll talk about it
right taken away building it flipping
all the money then
at 75 million
right yeah
3.25
that was what the bill was yeah I know
but that's that's what we're agreeing to
20-1
education
I want all those people to vote the
budget
okay I'll second that I'll make it quite
hard penguin
we're clear if you go to the next page
over the the busy one with all the
requests you'll see ccsnh online uh 51.
expand the Dual and concurrent
enrollment which is House Bill 520 oh
excuse me 420. so I I'll draft an
amendment to House Bill 2 and we will
overwrite essentially the governor's
level with that level of that bill works
so I will overwrite sections two through
five in House Bill 2 with
basically the contents from House Bill
420. and that will increase uh our
spending 1.25 million a year
that works
one of you said to me
he said
before
May the capital budget works
Treasurer comes in and tells them who
can borrow six percent of the total
revenue
otherwise our interest rates
so they start with that figure
and look at all the projects
I think they govern across they knew
this
they didn't see the winner
so one of them said to me no
we had some meetings at Whittemore
Center
good
so I said to shoot him what did we
paying a minute he put in my mouth and I
said we had a suggestion and if we're
gonna pay for this Whittemore Senate the
next time we need to meet there we're
not going to pay for it and Kathy our
professor said so
ordeal she said 20 grand wouldn't it I
believe I heard 20 grand
expensive because I don't know if they
put the floor down for us so when it was
something else
yes well I think it was just before the
season because we then we had to move
over to Manchester
you know
it's kind of
a little total thing but anyway it kind
of reminds them you know we help each
other here we saved money by opening our
mouths
so I know that's okay no no we don't we
don't he's good he's going to prepare it
as a an amendment where were you yeah it
was um implicit vote
accomplish it
I think we should wait for the full yeah
um
[Music]
it wasn't in there at all
so he took one out and put it in
um in our in division two so I couldn't
go back in because they still have to
have food so they told me there you go
they have one of them
and the other one begins
I think it also requires a vote
no no this is this is not the CTE
next Tuesday
could be on the bout next Tuesday
so we could wait
what my last conversational Mark he had
one of them ending the other one was a
matter of
if the district approves it doesn't go
back into the cap because they don't
have enough room
I think that's what happens
School
so the only place to come is back to
here
one of them's in there
already in this budget is in the capital
budget yeah well I don't I thought he
said that what's huge spending one is
put the building gate into something
is there any place we can see this
capital budget so you have it any place
when you see the capital budget you do
have the governor's recommended capital
budget in your binders and I don't think
there was any CTS in there and I don't
think public work
there's the the only doe Capital project
that I recall seeing was relative to
acquiring their building
to acquiring their building where
they're working out of on Hall Street
it was a there was a line item to buy
the building
for doe
yeah
that's I don't think there's any CT
um
projects in the governor's recommended
capital budget I'm not sure what work
Public Works and highways has done to
this point whether they've I know
they've heard from the Department on it
but I don't think they've made any
decisions to add the second one to this
point I'll double check with Chris in
our office just to see what the status
is of their work no no no that's what
I'm saying
you've got you've got the Sugar River
Valley whatever in House Bill 2 paid
with education trust funds I don't
believe there's anything in the capital
budget
there's no projects
that's the big one that's that's the
biggest the 12-5 yes
okay
that's all one one in one up yeah
so it was short seven and a half million
we've got 12 different requests from all
ctes hey we need money until we decided
here's what we're gonna do
two of you every two years
a list and then they have time to go to
the town
I think hope would threw that out the
window
most of us support it
in a million and a half
yeah but Washington State that's picking
a winner and a loser
they are getting
we are we talking with more
oh
yeah
nope I was uh thinking still about
Twitter more I just missed that portion
where we switched my bad no
interruptility
he likes it
so well
blockchain right
I don't know yeah
and blockchain crypto is one of the
applications the blockchain but
blockchain is way more than just the
crypto and it's a very common technology
well it's very powerful
you're a genius
so we'll hold on the UNH Appropriations
for now then by the sounds of it jumping
up a couple rows the retirement system
eligibility for ccsnh employees so on
in-house Bill 2 page two
like the front page here page two
section six and seven this is where
ccsnh has the house bill 2 Chain to
change to make any employees after
January 1st 2024 not be part of the
retirement system
well I think that's what they're doing
it changes
70.
maybe I should manage
this would be nice
so we'll hold on that one
I think so
a few years from now
foreign
and it's quite often
a lot of psychic scene you win those
conservatives you've got to get the vote
he didn't know he spoke
so going to page the third page again
I'm sorry for jumping around I'm just
trying to pick off what it might be low
hanging fruit here
uh on lines 19 and 20 the department of
safety had asked for uh some fire
service instructors and a program
assistant in the fire standards and
training Emergency Medical Services and
the fire safety divisions
based on on the page third yep flip to
page three there on on lines 19 and 20.
so about 790 for both of them and the
source of funds for this is the fire
fund and based on the actions that we
took earlier this week to accept the
Authority for the Department of Safety
to set the fees that go into the fire
fund through rules yeah they they you
know I think you can this isn't general
or Highway funds so if you're good with
establishing these positions from a
funding point of view you're good okay
we're good yeah
yep
yeah I'll I'll enter those so we'll
we'll enter those right into house bill
one so those will be shaded rose on here
now it's one one less item
uh I guess while we have this in front
of us is it helpful for the committee to
go through and if there's something that
you you have a consensus that you're not
going to do that you're just like yeah
take that off this list and and have you
more focused so this thing's not so busy
every time we meet that's an option or I
can still keep everything on here just
so you have it in case you want to refer
to it
um
at the end I'm going to give you a final
of everything you've done for sure so
it'll be
so flip over to page five essentially
flip a couple Pages it's that landscape
document
this is where I capture everything
you've done
you know so I'm keeping this as a
running tally of our of uh the changes
we've approved to this point
but I asked the committee about uh just
thought came to mind the uh on the port
on the
page four hb46a doe contract to recodify
education laws
do we have a thought on that one because
it seemed to me at the time and I'm just
sharing my recollection that one hundred
thousand was gonna be woefully
inadequate and that I don't think the
bill works with this amount and I don't
know that we're in a place to spend
millions of dollars to do it right so I
just wanted to hear where the committee
is on 468 I
you know it's the again the 100 000 to
recodify all the laws and there is no
way an attorney is going to get to 1200
pages
the bill is allocating a hundred
thousand to re-codify the Department of
Education laws which
is a woefully inadequate amount for that
and I'm not even sure if that project is
really something you know well it should
be done well yeah but years ago
when we talked about it we said that
there are other a number of departments
have to do this too that this is
something that was a big need and but it
took a lot it needs a lot more
discussion about how it would get done
so maybe it would be best to retain that
bill
okay so so we've acted on it
so well done all these bills we've acted
on they're carried on here just in case
you wanted to incorporate them into your
budget this is one that we had heard
testimony from the office of legislative
services that this is going to be a
pretty Herculean task and I don't think
they've really had a chance just because
of the nature of the time of year to
really look into this to give any sort
of direction for our committee and I
think the prime sponsor also was going
to check back and we haven't heard from
him either so so we are assuming so we
are assuming that for the purposes of
that budget cycle that will be out we
retain it for future action but we are
not gonna do this it's not gonna
I got you okay just shaking
I do have a drafted Amendment for the
hygiene products amendment that we work
through I can pass that around now just
so we have it
bye
the idea that well we told them to do it
and we didn't fund it
someone took us to court
on the billion dollars that we give to
education and said
you can't tell me to do that without
sending me extra money and it was a
small amount of money but they were
suing us for it and the court came back
and said they gave you a billion dollars
if they told you to do something else
with it then you're already doing
you've got the money don't come suing
them for more you can find it in the
billion dollars so I would take the same
attitude toward that hygiene products
that you know don't tell us we should
have given you
two thousand dollars or something I
agree when when you already gave you a
billion because that's that's my
recollection of what the court decided
when you give them a little change and
you're already given a billion dollars
and they take you to court saying you
should give me the 2 000. the court will
say take it out of the billion we don't
pay for toilets issue
that's right
anyway
how's things going in your
life
you're 77 years ago
that's why I'm sitting here
you really have to be supporting early
childhood education
the kids from Vermont
they have it over there yeah
I'll put 16.
back to the event
this all we did basically was take the
RSA as it was modified by
representative Edwards
and unmodified it quite a bit
the difference between this one and his
was he allocated twelve dollars per
Barrel I'll say the girl we have in here
administrating persons
um
he had twelve dollars
per student per year and we've dropped
it to three
he had
retroactive payments
which we dropped all together yeah
that's basically the difference someone
well
what's the what's the alternative
just leave them alone
so a couple I guess thoughts um I'm not
going to fall on any I'm not going to
fall on a razor blade for this I mean
this you know not that significant for
me but no I was going to say Blake fall
on my sword I figured well like razor
blade is much smaller than a sword yeah
I was just just a little thing there
um I guess one of the things that comes
to my mind uh was when our kids were in
school in California and the beginning
of the year the teacher would send home
kind of a list of requests all the
crayons are broken could would a parent
be willing to send in you know a couple
packages of crayons we don't have enough
Kleenex to get through the year would
y'all bring in would every family bring
in a box of Kleenex you know stuff like
that and this kind of falls into that
group and I don't want to ask the
parents to do this
I didn't like you know I certainly
brought in my box of Kleenex and my new
crayons to my kids but it's not
something that I think is really
inappropriate to ask parents to do
um I'm kind of the same mind I think as
the two of you sitting close together
over there on this one
um with regards to I have
I don't have any problem funding it if
that's the way we want to go but they do
have a big budget and you're talking
about a few dollars here and you're they
pay the paper towels they pay the toilet
paper there's you know any napkins in
the kitchen or whatever you know there
are any number of things so I said I'm
I'm either way on this I'd be happy to
support it um I think it's I think it's
unfortunate that we had to have the bill
in the first place because some schools
were not doing this but the bill we
passed takes care of that
and so as I said I'm of two minds here
yeah all this did was satisfy the 28a
I mean it's sticking it to the ceiling
them out of the machine
frankly well I think it's not going to
change I don't think I think this is a
part of Education of those young girls
you know at some point you started to
behave yourself but
correct
the the issue is that the statute
specifically said available in the
bathrooms right if I recall correctly
and that's what leads to the waste
because there is no adult supervision in
the bathroom and kids will be kids so
honestly the question is if the waste is
significant whether maybe the house
should consider going back to making the
products available without specifying in
the bathrooms but again there were
considerations and reasons why that bill
is passed so I don't want to get into a
big policy thing here you know
together
and you do all this and then you look up
on the mirror and kiss the mirror right
when they are custodian when they saw
him doing it went over and said I'm
going to clean these mirrors off I'm
going to put it drag into the toilet got
to wet and whatever
[Laughter]
thank God you are not on the mic though
well do you want to wait till we have
the full committee on this one all right
um
it's just are they going to start asking
for paper because they don't give them
enough School sure
I mean why is this
I don't know all those other things
that's what I'm
the racers pencils people no no I'm
saying that we've specified that they
have to have do we specify they have to
have paper and pencils
States
goes away
oh here's here's the person though I
wasn't this is this was Pat enacted when
I was on vacation
so I didn't hear any of the
deliberations or anything about this
would you want to raise up would you
want three then no I was at home oh
yeah but it was you would you assigned a
three no it was on one oh
so
my attitude is is get rid of the whole
thing
what's up but well I got 28 age but the
issue was
there were testimony that said some
young women were staying home a week a a
month
because of non-availability the issue
seems to what I'm hearing is that the
problem is have the the phrase of keep
having it available in the bathroom and
just having the bill without that phrase
sort of covers they have to have these
materials available but not specify that
it's the bathroom because many schools
use the gym teacher or the nurse or you
know one of those but the issue was some
schools simply not doing it at all but
putting it in the bathroom I think has
caused the hiccup here no well
but here's the thing though as somebody
who raised two girls or is in the
process of
there is definitely a awkwardness and
the discouragement if kids have to go to
the nurse's office for this while I
agree that bathroom is not a good place
to put them if we are gonna Tinker with
a language which is fine
I would suggest that we put something
that cannot be interpreted to just going
back right to the nurse's office you
know available through other teachers or
counselors or you know it's got to be
somebody that the kid is not afraid of
going to or not embarrassed by uh
because trust me kids are vicious
sometimes you go to the nurse's office
and everybody's gonna make all the kind
of jokes about you know your time of the
month and the whole point is to avoid
that right so we got to be careful if we
play with a language to not recreate
that issue which is real for girls you
know in high in schools so
you know it can be other trusted people
you know teachers counselors whatever it
doesn't have to be a trip to the nurses
I'm fine with removing it from the
bathroom but I urge you to be careful if
we play with a language to not go back
to just a nurse's office even on
International well we have an amendment
interesting that we would be talking
about this to come walking in
we talk further about it his Amendment
eliminated the bathroom specifications
okay isn't that what my amendment is no
no this one has the bathroom
specifications
still in
okay
the reason I did my amendment was
why are we micromanaging schools right
but do we know better what goes on in
schools than they themselves know
right I mean
principals and teachers and everybody
they they're the ones who run the school
so you tell them
here's some you know money for you and
and here's something to do with it let
them do it let them figure out what
works for them and what doesn't you know
that's all why why do we have to we
don't have to be that detailed on
something like this that's that that's
what I thought
a lot of girls
fifth grade sixth grade
um
do you have a copy of that Amendment
it is yeah so of all the things I
thought I'd ever be talking about
I didn't start this
all right but this being said I mean if
we
amend the existing statute to
change it so that they are easily
available but not require them in the to
be in the bathroom I think that whole
unfunded mandate problem goes away
because really the objection was to the
waste
from having them in an unsupervised
location I don't remember you know
that's what I remember if I would
appreciate if somebody corrected me if
I'm not right
like
maybe we should wait for the full
committee
it was it was just it was really just
that one line that specifies the
bathroom yeah if you if you crossed out
it said basically just make them
available it didn't say where yes
available at no cost
and probably middle and high school and
you're suggesting you're putting it
at the elementary
well why not say schools
hang on could we see in schools you know
with
kids of a certain age or
we are gonna get in trouble when
somebody's gonna have to stock uh you
know uh
menstruating products in a kindergarten
that doesn't have the rest of it I'm
just saying Public Schools is a very
broad term I would suggest if we are
gonna change the language to have
language that addresses representative
Lads point that younger kids than Middle
School can menstruate but I I wouldn't
want to make it super broad to avoid
waste
like what that's what I'm saying I mean
there's got to be more management
and bathroom designer
are available at no cost
what do we
Mary doesn't want to Pony up to three
bucks per
yes
I do I do agree though with the point
made by representative Heath earlier
that
it's probably better to remove the
perceived unfunded mandate which is
related to that waste than to start
appropriating for every little thing
that we ask of schools at the end of the
day that's what the you know big budget
is for
foreign
so do away with the whole thing
I
so you're you're against Mary
the the you want to do away with the
whole thing so we don't have a 28-day
issue thank you
and it was setting a bad president
do you just want to get rid of the money
steps now you get a 28 day issue even
though it's minor
I can't remember these there
getting a huge they're all getting a big
they've already got a big budget already
and this is not a significant amount to
that and we're already funding yeah so
it's not on concept but uh we don't you
know it's not unfunded we're giving them
plenty of funding it's up to them to
decide how to appropriate their funding
so it's not a 28a violation then no no
okay
so that's so we Mickey you got that
so
say no what what that you're not going
to adopt an amendment yeah I think I got
that okay good yeah so we'll we'll put
this aside no wait wait wait but we were
going to take out the in all gender
neutral bathrooms and we're getting it
taking out the bathroom language the
school district shall make menstrual
hygiene products available at no cost
for females located for females
attending public middle and high schools
middle and high school how about just
Public Schools I would be fine with that
that works and apropos what you're
saying if it's a you know you're not
going to put them in the kindergarten if
there's no one there to use it but this
is such an important teacher has need of
it the fourth grade teacher who will
have access to it
but I mean seriously we say all public
schools we are going to run straight
into you know K through two schools now
having to start really yeah lots of
people the language says shall
that's what I'm saying I would it needs
to be qualified Beyond Public Schools if
we do this
no I wouldn't say that
foreign
there's discourse to be had when some
other areas there's not a whole lot of
discourse going on
um what if you you know
um amended the females of available at
no cost for menstruating females in
public schools
that would work perfectly fine that's my
point you gotta narrow it down to the
population so we avoid
you know the uh
and honestly I think the current
language is menstruating menstruating
students and uh
instead of penetrating females what
should we use menstruating
administrating students
because then you'll avoid them yeah they
get enough money to supply I think
students is more specific the 28a just
went away was technically menstruating
the person would apply to staff too
unless it's already in order to provide
this to the staff
so what do we decide we're going to call
these people I think it was menstruating
students demonstrating students okay
foreign
and is there any
thought on you know how we make sure
that this is not going all the way back
to square one where this was just
available at the North nurse and the
walk-up shame to the nurse's office
I mean
that was available let them figure
yeah I think that that's a school policy
and the problem that this addressed
wasn't that exactly it was that nothing
was available nothing was available just
bringing up potential concerns because
again
I've heard
on Friday afternoon at 3 30 at 3 30. so
so in in just a
just to remind everyone so we retained
this bill for fiscal reasons
we retain this bill for fiscal reasons
and now has no fiscal impact right yeah
that's right we're doing
um
it's still within the you know our
Authority if you wanted to schedule
another work session on
House Bill 129 with this amendment and
keep it out of House Bill 2 and not
retain it and have to deal with it in
the summer or we still can put this
amendment in-house Bill to even though
it has no fiscal implications
either way is acceptable it's really up
to the committee
split it out so in that case I'll work
with Janet to post a notice because we
we've got a few others that we retained
but you may realize you don't they're
not going to be part of House Bill too
so and we can talk Mr chair if we want
to identify a couple another one that
jumps to mind is the house bill 638
relative to the extraordinary needs
Grant accountability plan that was
something that we talked about today
depending on what you do with that that
bill may be able to be dealt with on its
own since it's not going to be probably
part of House Bill too we know now
nope
uh no no it doesn't
so but I'll we can talk we can talk
after about that but we talked earlier
about extraordinary needs reporting
correct and said
recently italed it right correct to take
that will go in House Bill too okay
we'll keep that in the house I'm asking
the question as much yes yes yes but yes
that's uh we'll we'll stick with that
and with House Bill too and I'm just
saying well we can still retain it if
you want as well just we'll deal with it
in the summer as well okay but all right
I only have a couple other things if you
I don't know how much of a break you
want before your meeting later let's get
her done okay uh I let me see I'll pass
this letter out uh chairman Emrick and
the committee got a letter from uh
councilor Kenny
today relative to public transit Matt
what's up when I increase it I don't
want no freaking trains no it's not
trained this is like coaches oh in the
old Coast
yeah
oh okay all right
yeah they name them here
Tri-County Transit North Country
Advanced Transit Upper Valley
I'm not sure what the match rate is and
if the match is consistent over all the
dollars but if you recall the department
did bring this in as part of their uh
division of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
requests on
on our tracking sheet packet on page
three of this
if you go to the Department of
Transportation on line 38 you'll see the
corresponding increase that would fund
this request in this letter
the 1.8 on top of what is our page three
page three line
38.
so they
uh there's already about a million in
the budget
so this additional 1.8 would bring it up
to the amount that's requested which I
think was like 2.75 million I'm just
using round numbers
I got left off the list no that's stupid
no that's pretty it's Representatives oh
organs on there all the whole delegation
it lets me on some of it huh well I feel
rejected if you have it look at this oh
it's right there it's organ I actually
met with uh the transportation provider
that works
is a subset of coast
no this is this is me gentlemen can we
talk about the content
um
and what what's happened
is these Transportation companies are
doing a lot of medical transportation
senior transportation
and they do get some federal
reimbursement but it's insufficient for
what they're required to do
so every time they go on a federal run
they get a little bit of money but it
costs more so the better they do the
worse off they are
sounds like a good Federal program to me
so that's why they they were soliciting
to increase the allocation I think
there's seven of these
Transportation companies around I didn't
count them but he I think he indicated
there's seven uh like them like Coast
around the state
and this money gets divvied up between
the seven of them
yeah I I didn't get into the match I
just he just talked about raw dollars
if we're so inclined uh you would add
correct there's a million in the budget
already so you'd get I'm just using
round numbers so I'm looking at the uh
the class line uh 73 the non-federal
grants for public transportation and
there's
uh 500 000 a year budget in there which
most of that if not all is probably
related to this this specific request
came forward from the Department of
Transportation the 1.883
for the remaining to do the full match
so that's
that plus what's already in the budget
would bring it up to the amount
requested in this letter
I think it's rounded to 2.75 in here
correct
about this
I I can't speak to every budget I know
there has been budgets we have done this
match before I don't know the way I look
at it we can put it on the list and if
we don't have enough money we can take
it off the list
would you
so put it on the list as in you're
approving that ad at this point right
just as long as we understand that we
may need to revisit everything we do is
tentative just yeah and I'll I'll update
our tracking sheet that that's been made
we'll carry it when Mike Kane does his
updates for the committee as a whole and
then if later on in the process you have
to revisit anything it can be done just
making sure at the end we may get
together and say okay each division
or get more right oh yeah that's gonna
happen
you're able to division two didn't cut
anyone
that was a good that was a good deal
two fourth
100 million
then
a few years before it came from repaid
Creations from Brooks tax cuts
to take three one issue overseas
so sooner we had to hold us project
one-time project
came to here soon forward threw it all
out
said we'll grow government
particular wrong answer when you hit one
time
so we found that 80 million of 0.2
HHS equipments
on the city that's terrible
balance the budget two years
I probably like I've never seen four
distantly
right here I
remember getting the money
make anything else
I think this might be a good place to to
stop for today I think we've gotten
everything through this I think is
pretty easy that we uh with our missing
members
I would just say that we are running out
of time as everyone knows
um next week next week we have a work
session on Monday at 10 o'clock doe will
be here
in the afternoon we have our public
hearing at two o'clock in reps Hall
Tuesday we have a full day scheduled
here but I'm also hearing we have a
weather event potentially so we'll see
what happens with that oh and it's also
town meeting day so I don't know who it
will be in available for that
uh Wednesday I think we've got
essentially a full day with full
committee
and then Thursday there's a session day
which I think surprised us that there
was a session day this week
on the 16th well they are trying to you
know hopefully not have three of them
the next week so and we may get one on
the back end
I'm here
I'm available
no I have nothing scheduled for a
Saturday at this point by middle of the
week if I'll leave it up to the chair in
the committee to decide that
and then yes because the following week
is where we're asked to hold three days
for sessions potentially and so yeah I
think is it down to two because we're
gonna go next week so that following
Tuesday should be open the following
week one of the days maybe two but not
three okay
I think uh two of the days were said to
be sessions the Wednesday and Thursday
yes and they said Hold Tuesday but if
that Tuesday it becomes available for us
that'll be good that'll Monday and
Tuesday of that week we'll have to work
which will be fine but that Thursday is
our deadline the 23rd we're fast
approaching so
I would say if anyone has any amendments
that you would like drafted anything you
want to try to run anything you want to
work through with me to be prepared for
next week or whenever don't hesitate to
reach out
but I'll update these documents based on
our decisions today
and uh
we'll have a fresh starting point for
Monday when we have Doe okay well with
with Theo once we get through Doe
um
the next
it's a variety look at the top of the
sheet
yeah
and that that doesn't seem to be one
Department I see UNH oh yes yeah ccs and
H you have that one retirement set
system section then the UNH items and
then basically the rest is doe with the
exception of that one it rights of way
relative to the prime Wetlands that we
held but everything else is doe related
so I'm hoping uh just to be able to walk
through each of those sections with the
Department Monday so and the second page
is also all doe yeah the only thing
that's not doe specific is uh the last
two sections relative to the education
trust fund distribution of uh business
Revenue business tax revenue so I think
that's up in the air what this committee
is going to do with the education trust
fund as a whole so
well it really depends on other other
items
best deal yes all those sections are doe
related mostly education funding related
and there is an updated on let's say
I don't know page six perhaps I'll put
page numbers on this to make it easier
for next week the education trust fund
snapshot with all of your changes coming
into today
so you can see you know the removal of
the 75 million dollars for the
School building Aid fund you also
increase tuition and transportation by
2.2 million a year and then we're also
going to carry that snap expansion of
the fnr population adjustment you'll see
that on line 38 30 million over the
biennium so after all those changes
there's still 104 million dollars in the
education trust fund is your current
position
we'll solve that yeah
so as I look down
as I look on the second page that 75
million dollars is line
item 59.
ah correct yeah from house bill 2. so
that that'll be
yep we'll draft an amendment that'll
delete that essentially okay so once
once that's uh drafted I think it just
wasn't prepared for today's packet
that's all right I'll have that in there
yep I'm just
figuring it out yeah
my point being that once we have doe in
we'll pretty much knock out hv2
you'll
be with a couple of big decisions to
make I think school building Aid is
still in question as well as just your
education funding proposal what you want
to do with that compared to the
governors you have a couple of bills
that changed education funding so I
think all that is many of these House
Bill 2 sections but at least after you
have doe in you'll have heard from all
the agency folks and we've gone through
every section so we should be familiar
with the content and then it's just up
to decisions
they said there was a conflict with some
of the bills that were passed can we get
an explanation or you know a little
chart to explain the the conflicts and
what we need to do to fix that
uh are you talking about from yesterday
so yeah uh
a couple of the esa related bills that
passed yesterday relative to eligibility
expanding the eligibility
let's see so house bill
367 increase the income threshold from
300 percent of federal poverty to 350.
then House Bill 464 passed which added
all those expanded criteria of
Eligibility that we also see in House
Bill 2 but also re also included the
section of the income eligibility for
all students at 300 percent so
you had two bills passed yesterday one
with three hundred percent one with 350
percent of federal poverty you have that
section of law in-house Bill too so this
committee can decide what you want to do
with an amendment to align it with the
house policy that passed those bills
didn't get referred to us so those are
going to cross over to the Senate so
this committee can decide what you want
to do as far as aligning with the bills
that pass what bills will not be
referred to us
464 367 and 440. will not be referred to
us why
don't know but they do have a physical
impact never mind I get that they would
but and we can address it with I know
I'm just trying to understand the
mechanics I'm new again yeah
and then the 440 is a bill that is
similar to what is in the governor's
house bill to relative to all the uses
of the education trust fund including uh
provision allowing the Department of
Education to retain up to a certain
amount of the education trust fund for
administration so we haven't got to
those sections yet of House Bill too
they're they're hopefully we can cover
those with the department but those
pieces of legislation did pass so it'll
be up to this committee whether you want
to just mirror essentially what pass or
if you want to do anything different
than essentially the house would have
two different versions of laws passing
thank you
in the House Bill 2 there is
in 464 that passed yesterday there was
not
so that's one of the just differences
between what the bill is before you
House Bill 2 versus what is already past
the house
um what's that cost the difference
between uh 350 and 500 I don't know
we're not getting I don't know estimates
for foreign
no it's no 500. the education Freedom
account program has a provision similar
to adequacy that however much is needed
for it the department should draw a
warrant from the education trust fund to
pay for it on that
this time there's actually an amount
in-house Bill too that's only 29 million
dollars a year so we don't have any
other numbers to go on you can ask the
department about it Monday if they have
any information
300 and one bill about 350. we'll make
the ones 300 350.
HP tune says 500.
well I was 350. almost that's what I'm
saying okay but but hb2 already has 500
so so hp2 and the last bill
they won't we're done well that's that's
the idea yeah but I you know I just want
to understand
which one are you going to pick I mean
we can pick it's not even coming to us
but we can change it
but it's not even defined
over here
of the education trust fund but this is
I agree I would too
that's a good question
so this is this is a Monday conversation
uh the one percent
I mean I can point you to where it is in
House Bill 2 and you can read but I I
can't answer
when they're here when they're here I
would certainly ask them why that's
in-house Bill 2 and how they intend the
application of that statute would work
the way it's written is there another
unusual I would I would say is there any
other agency that has that kind of a
provision
they're they're yeah
and I think
yeah we don't we're not providing grants
to them we're funding their work so it's
yeah
generally when there's a uh provision
for an agency to take money to
administer a program it's usually not
State funds with this being State funds
I think it's pretty unusual that because
doe is funded with State funds and then
to take a piece of estate fund to
administer that state fund there's I
don't think it sounds like you've only
paid twice
I think what there is an administrative
account
let me back up there is a new accounting
unit in the budget for ETF
Administration which started last budget
which is mostly I.T related I believe
Data Systems
so one thing that that section could be
modified to do is just say that the
education trust fund may be used for
administrative costs of the Department
of Education as determined by the
general court so rather than a one
percent just kind of an up to whatever
amount it's just really whatever you put
in the budget is all they can spend and
I think maybe that could have been what
they were going for and they just used a
language that kind of aligns with other
types of Grants or federal programs but
I think working through it with that
Monday is the way to go
because that's like 10 million dollars
and it's unclear who determines the up
to
so I mean one percent one percent of a
billion dollars
never
we could administer the efas in-house
for that
sorry
yeah I wish we could keep that 10 in New
Hampshire
just so you'll know the uh there there's
an accountability for administration
and funds in excess of of that 10
percent flowing
flow to the students
it's not it's not a profit line for the
administrators
we're making it sound like 100 million
dollars they're keeping 10 million
dollars that's not the case
10 million dollars is a sign for
administration what they don't consume
and justify flows out to the students
wait a second so you're saying
the lowest organization
is allowed to take 10 percent
of each and people of each education
account
um so you're saying they don't I'm
saying they don't
I I think they did but they don't
according to according to them
okay
that's that was represented by the
I guess she's the owner okay yeah she's
but but she said
what they don't use in administration is
an additional funding that goes out to
this
okay
the point is well she's got 10 employees
and and you're not going to do it with
one administrative person
so much
across the country
what case what case name a case
foreign